this is Joo podcast number 401 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Ekko good
evening the military advisory command
Vietnam studies and observation group
Mac
vog don't be misled by the name we are
not an academic group studying the war
in Vietnam we were not advising
anyone Mac vog was a top secret group of
the most elite special operations
Warriors in the
world every time I led my team on a
mission it was kill or be killed every
time hundreds sometimes thousands of
people would
die it was not about Rules of Engagement
was this person an enemy does this
person have a weapon is this person
about to kill me or the other questions
and rules today's special operators may
have to deal with saw GR rules were very
different and
simple everyone was the enemy the enemy
had to be terminated or you would
be and if the enemy caught you the
United States government would deny any
involvement with you or what you were
doing you had no protection under the
Geneva Convention you were a
spy you were on your
own it has been documented that SOG
teams had the highest kill ratio of any
unit during the Vietnam era SOG teams
also had the highest casualty rate over
200% this means each SOG member was
either killed or wounded multiple
times for example Staff Sergeant Robert
Howard later Colonel Howard was wounded
on at least 11
occasions was awarded eight purple
hearts the distinguished service cross a
and the Medal of
Honor 22 men received the distinguished
service cross and 13 received the Medal
of Honor on SOG
operations there has never been a war
where such small teams of Young Warriors
were set against such overwhelming
numbers of enemy forces on every
Mission but the sog missions were not
fought alone you were always part of a
team internal battles however were and
still are being fought Alone by what has
been burned into each SOG operator's
brain once seen you cannot
unsee once you do you cannot
undo there are experiences on the
battlefield that you can never unsee
unhear UNS smell unfe or un
taste Once you pull the trigger or
detonate an explosive the lives you have
just terminated cannot be
unkilled the enemies the enemy soldiers
spouse kids grandkids great grandkids
future relatives and potential roles
they all play in the history of the
world are immediately and permanently
erased you can never forget the look on
the person's face when you pull the
trigger or penetrate him with your
knife these are part of you for the rest
of your life
you can never remove the experience from
your brain it is part of you until you
die and that right there is an excerpt
from the
intro of a book that is called SOG code
name Dynamite a Mac VG one Z's personal
Journal which is written by Henry dick
Thompson and on the cover of the book
there's a quote from Major General Elden
barwell Alle Legend from SOG and from
United States Special Operations and the
quote from him
says I thought I was crazy until I saw
what Thompson did when he became my SOG
team leader in
1969 now dick Thompson has been on this
podcast before he was on episodes 200 4
206 back in late 2019 and on those
episodes we covered some of his
experiences and some of his lessons
learned from the Vietnam War we also
covered his book which is a book that he
had written called the stress effect
which is a book about leadership and
decision making written about his
knowledge from his time as a military
officer as a SOG operator leadership
consultant and a PhD in Psychology by
the way so go listen to those podcast
for some background but in this new
book code named
Dynamite he gives us details about some
of his SOG missions in
Vietnam the book is an incredible read
and I have read a lot of military books
and it gives us some insight into the
missions and the mindset of these
amazing SOG Warriors and it's an
absolute honor to have dick Thompson
with us here again to talk through this
book his experiences and some of his
lessons learned sir thank you for
joining us again thank you for having me
back I'm glad you could make it
out me
too um that's been almost I guess three
or four years since the last time you
were was
2019 so it's been a while um and the
last time you were on you know we talked
through some of your some of the stuff
in the beginning is just about how you
grew up and and you cover that you cover
that in this book as
well about you growing up in the
woods about you being a general at a
young age you were you were actually a
general in charge of your own Rangers a
group of a group of Rangers a regiment
of Rangers that was made up of your
cousins and your
friends uh you played football you ran
track you had an interest in chemist
chemistry which included the interest in
blowing things up and shooting Rockets
into the sky so
you graduated high school in 1965 you
start college at the University of South
Carolina again we covered this on on
podcast
204 um and you do cover it some of that
with a little more detail in the
book but in you know you're you you went
to college for a year and the Vietnam
War at this time is
escalating and you wanted to get into it
so you enlisted in the Army um you
volunteer for airborne School you
volunteer to become an officer and get
selected to become an officer you
volunteer for Special
Forces you go to the Q course you
actually had orders that were not going
to send you to Vietnam so you
volunteered for
Vietnam and you are rewarded with going
to Vietnam and I remembered asking you
the last time you were on you
volunteered for all these things you got
selected and I said was it hard to get
selected and you said hey it was the
Vietnam War like oh you want to be
special forces yep come on over here oh
you want to be airborne come on over
here you want to be an officer come on
over here the life expectancy of
officers was so short at that time they
were filling those gaps up as quick as
they
could um but like I said you cover that
in in the beginning of this book and and
with with a little more detail I mean
with a lot more detail than I just said
but that was the path you were on from
being a little kid until the point you
you get shipped off to Vietnam you
you're done with the Q of course you've
been to Ranger school um been to special
forces training and it's time to go to
Vietnam
um and I was going to skip right ahead
you know get to some of the missions but
I I I just had to cover this part when
you get to Vietnam um I'm going to go to
the book here again the book is called
code name dynamite and we'll get to that
as
well so you arrive in Vietnam
uh it says we went quickly through the
Customs arrival procedures then we were
transported to Reception Center for in
processing a special forces Sergeant
gathered up those of us who were going
to a special forces assignment and took
us on a short ride to n Trang there we
were temporarily we were assigned
temporary quarters given instructions
for the next day and fed Bob and Bob is
your buddy Who You'd gone through all
this training with you became friends in
in uh AIT I think Bob and I made contact
with Captain John Smith
a friend of ours from Fort Brag he got
to Vietnam a few weeks ahead of us and
was already working in a mic Force
another good friends of ours first
lieutenant Ray Stax from Fort Bragg had
left four weeks ahead of us but we had
no idea where he had been assigned John
updated us on things that were going on
in country especially with the Ted
offensive Special Forces and the types
of SF assignments we might want to ask
for the next
day he said tomorrow toward the end of
the day one of the last things they are
going to do is ask you if you want to
volunteer for
SOG do not do it regardless of how cool
they make it sound do not volunteer for
SOG just tell them no if you volunteer
you will die almost all of them die the
ones who don't die get the crap shot out
of them from several times and they
return to the states a nutcase don't do
it just say no they'll say thank you and
you'll move on to your special forces
assignment we'll meet back tomorrow
evening and you can tell me about your
assignments I might know some people
where you're going we spent the evening
talking about old times and various
aspects of the culture his parting words
were remember what I said do not
volunteer for
SOG so you weren't a very good listener
at this point I take it obviously
not uh I'm going to fast forward a
little bit it's the next day and you
meet a guy with a guy named colonel
colonel
Jones and he says uh I see that you
volunteered for the Army OCS Airborne
Special Forces Rangers and Vietnam and
now you have the opportunity to
volunteer for the most important job
that you will ever have based on what I
see in your file you are perfect for the
job this is a job that is so Elite that
only the people who do it know what it
is if you take this job no one will ever
know that you did it
where you did it or what you did it will
not be in your records you cannot tell
anyone and you will have to sign papers
agreeing not to tell anyone it is very
rare that I offer this opportunity to
anyone but I'm offering you what do you
think I said it would help it would help
if I knew what the job was he said I
understand all I can say is that you
will be volunteering to go anywhere and
do anything no questions asked I asked
are you asking me if I want to join
SG he said is that what you want to do I
looked him in the eyes and said
yes he said are you sure
Lieutenant I
replied
yes fast forward a little bit I went to
the bar that evening to meet John when
he saw me walking up to the bar he said
you did it I can see it on your face
you're a freaking dead Dead Man Walking
I told you not to do it crap I thought
you were smarter than that bartender
give this stupid son of a a double
Jack and Coke when John saw Bob walking
up to the bar he said you did it too I
can see it in your face you are both
Dead Men Walking I told you two not to
do it crap Boba I thought you were
smarter than Thompson bartender give
this stupid son of a a double Jack
and Coke John repeated his remarks about
what we had done several times during
the
evening so there you go you're in
SOG how much did you know about
it very little um you know I had heard
the word kicked around some at Brag uh
no one really knew what it what it was
or what people did they would just say
things like you know these guys are
crazy they do really cool things and
nobody knows what don't look at that guy
don't make eye contact with him he's
rumored to have been in sock those guys
are
nutcases you make eye contact with him
you may disappear tonight and your body
will never be found they're
crazy okay what's weird about this
is look there's all kinds of room you
know when I came when I joined the Navy
and I was uh trying to go to Seal
training you know you'd hear these kind
of these kind of same
things with SOG it's true like all the
stuff that you're hearing is true with
the sealed teams and with the regular uh
you know Special Operations
guys this is the only case I can think
of where it is just absolutely freaking
true what you guys were doing what you
were getting into you know if I would
have gotten told that when I was uh 21
year old or 20 years old or 19 years old
when I joined up of course yeah I'll go
but you you don't think it's G to be
what they what it's advertised as you
hope it's going to be what it's
advertised as but boy did you guys get
what it was advertised as didn't you did
you had you ever talked to somebody that
was SOG beforehand yep
no not not that I knew about no so they
they did a legit job of keeping it
secret and not letting anybody know
what's going
on all right and you think uh what about
a 34 year-old dick Thompson you think
you would have volunteered for it then
when you were 34 or you think this is a
young man's game it's mostly A L young
man's game
but I did some wacky stuff as it got
older
too I mean once once I had been in soag
you know everything else looked
relatively tame um you know whether it
was uh making a Halo jump you know in
the dark trying to go into a small LZ in
the mountain
someplace uh it you know you just keep
getting smaller and smaller lzs to uh
run the adrenaline level up it just
whatever the biggest one of the biggest
uh issues to deal with was uh trying to
show enough
restraint
because like you mentioned before in in
SOG the rules were
different and you had so much freedom in
terms of what you could do or had to do
that when when you came back to the real
world it was a matter of I don't like
what that person
said I would really like to rip his face
off but I'm not going to do that I'd
like to make this person disappear but
I'm not going to do that and it was just
constantly I'm not going to do that I'm
going to restrain myself and you know I
had been taught that to some degree you
know in martial arts before I went in in
the military know you can do it know you
have the capability to take the guy down
but back away you don't have to do it
because you can show restraint but this
was a much more violent type of
restraint and just for people listening
how how long have you been in the Army
for at this point like maybe approaching
two years about two years and you're 21
years old 21 21 years
old um in case you can't tell just order
the book right now I'm I'm obviously not
going to read the whole thing
but there it's just an epic book so just
order it um just go order it so you can
read this stuff I'm going to fast
forward a little bit now you're you're
heading up so so now you're in SOG you
volunteered and now you head up to uh
fob4 and it says when the fob4 CCN
Commander walked in we all stood at
attention he said at EAS take your seats
I'm Lieutenant Colonel Warren let me
tell you what s is about and what you
have volunteered to do that you can
never tell anyone about you have
volunteered to serve in the military
advisory command Vietnam studies and
observations group mat V SOG this is
your official assignment and if you
believe you are here to do studies and
observations on what happens in Vietnam
then you are dumber than an effing board
and you need to leave now if you stay
you can never leave not alive
anyways you have just become a member of
the most elite fighting force in the
world you have volunteer to go anywhere
and do anything you can never tell
anyone about it if that's not what
you're here for leave now once I start
the briefing you are all in am I clear
we responded Yes
sir Lieutenant Colonel Warren explained
that MC vog was a top secret
multi-service US Special Operations
Force unit established 24 January 1964
to conduct unconventional warfare
operations in Southeast Asia associated
with the Vietnam War operations took
place in South Vietnam North Vietnam La
Cambodia and other Southeastern
Southeast Asian areas as required MC vog
had participated in the most significant
campaigns of the Vietnam War in short he
said we are North Vietnam's worst
nightmare he goes on to tell you about
the missions types of missions recover
imprisoned and Miss missing Americans
training agents for insertion into North
Vietnam Black psychological operations
raids and ambushes prisoner snatches
assassinations doctored ammunition
document retrieval wire Taps pipeline
destruction b50 2 bomb damage assessment
Search and Destroy and other missions as
assigned and you mentioned in the book
like when you saw those missions or you
heard about those
missions there was nothing that really
surprised you these were kind of all the
mostly the type of op operations that
you've been prepared for through soft SF
training and Rangers as well yeah I mean
all of those
topics it's up for maybe the doctored
ammunition you know we had trained for
but to do uh in in Vietnam to do against
whatever enemy so the list didn't shock
us it was just we're we're going to go
do it
because um you know I had volunteered to
go to Vietnam because I thought
Vietnam's where it is I mean that's
where we're fighting the war that's
what's going on uh and then when I got
into s all of a sudden I realized
um my mail is going to be sent to Saigon
in
Vietnam and everybody my family
everybody's going to think I'm in
Vietnam and I'm fighting a war in
Vietnam really that's just where I store
my
gear that's where I go to train that's
where I go to get my mission but when I
go to war I'm going to have a combat
deployment into other Southeast Asian
countries so you know i' I've been in
like six different countries uh to go
fight in everybody thought I was
fighting in Vietnam if you look at the
the Tombstones of the guys who were
killed in
SG all of them say
Vietnam that's not where they were
killed none of them were killed there
you know you were killed in other
countries your family everyone was told
you were killed in Viet now uh when my
family sent a mail to me it went to uh
post office box in uh Saigon it was
opened it was read and scanned and then
sent to me to whatever fob I was in you
know and I would get it and read it when
I responded back to my family or anyone
that I wrote to it went to Saigon it was
opened it was read uh to make sure there
was nothing in there
classified if if it was that letter you
know was just lost
so Vietnam was just you know kind of
like a TDY station I was there to to get
ready to go fight someplace MH I mean we
we did some operations in Vietnam yeah I
was going to say in North Vietnam and
but even in South Vietnam we we did a
lot of uh fighting there just training
yeah let's let's go find some guys over
here and and because what we wanted in
the
training that I think is missing a lot
today and I won't get on that soap box
but you you just can't imagine uh the
effectiveness of having live fire shoot
back targets you know you can go out and
shoot a silhouette all day and it
doesn't shoot back at you and you can
take your time you can get good side of
alignment you can aim you can shoot at
it you hit it it falls over and it pops
back up but when it comes back up it
doesn't shoot at you and you know in in
the first mission in the book there I
discovered when people when those
targets start shooting back and there's
a whole bunch of them shooting back um
your stress level goes up and everything
changes your vision Chang you can't
focus on your sight so you can't aim
like you were training to aim uh you
can't load your you know your magazine
in in the weapon you can't even get it
out of your pouch with all those bullets
coming at you because you've never been
like that before yeah so yeah one thing
that we were and I don't know if you
ever got to use any of this stuff but by
the late 90s we we had simunition so and
we were using it it would go in your
real gun you know you had adaptive
Barrel and you'd put simunition in there
and the the you know my my thought was
like you said you go and fight paper
targets paper targets don't do the two
things that the enemy does which is
shoot back and maneuver on you so as
soon as you had simunition you're
getting shot your guys are getting shot
and the enemy is now maneuvering on you
and it becomes a much more
realistic uh simulation of combat and it
was really good for working with leaders
you know the the the the military the
young seal leaders that were going to
have to make decisions and make things
happen cuz they had to observe they had
to run that UDA Loop in their head and
observe what was happening Orient
themselves decide what to do and then
act on it and get the platoon to act on
it so that was a huge step up for us
when we started being able to use and we
ended up with a we also ended up with a
with a really high-speed laser tag
system that we would use in the in
Outdoors so the the paintball is good in
in closer terrain like in a in a city
environment because you can you know you
can shoot 30 or 40 meters and it'll be
okay but the the uh laser simulators
that we had you know you could shoot
someone at like 400 400 meters so it it
was pretty good and you had machine guns
and they had a little speaker on your
shoulder when you get shot at would make
snaps going over your head and if you
got wounded it would tell you you're
wounded if you got killed it would tell
you you're killed you lay down it was a
really good training system um but still
falling short of what you guys had over
on marble Mountain where You' go out and
find enemy to go fight for your training
operations so we'll get to some of that
but um going back to the book here you
say we also got to pick out our official
code names I wanted Ranger but Bob spoke
up before me and asked for Ranger then I
saw dynamite and I thought it was
fitting for me seeing as I always like
to blow things up and I was relatively
small Dynamite would work for me I had
blown up my NE I'd blown my neighbor's
windows out when I was a teenager with a
rocket that exploded on its Launchpad I
didn't intend for that to happen but I
was always blowing things up I figured
I'd probably be blowing things up in
Southeast Asia and I did get to blow up
a lot of things Bridges helicopters bad
guys Munitions dumps Etc I always
carried a lot of C4 and other explosives
with me it would be my code name to
identify myself if I were wounded or
something bad happened to me so that's
where Dynamite came so they just had a
list of names up on the up on the wall I
mean different C call call signs that
you could take yeah they had a list and
you know it it was important that you
had a name uh that would identify you if
you were captured uh if you were killed
uh to have a a name that if it was used
we we knew who it was without telling
anything else about you uh if you needed
to send some kind of message when you if
you were captured and still alive then
you know by working that word into
whatever you were sending then you know
it was it was sending a message out and
and
ironically um you you didn't just have
the code name you also had some other
questions uh about
you the name of your
dog you know what what was your first
car and when you think about it that's
the same thing you do now that's like
the internet security question that's
all those questions that's where they
came from was was back then you still
had to have those uh because the
likelihood of of you being um captured
you know was pretty high you'd probably
die most of the time they just kill you
um but you could be captured and they
wanted all these different methods so
you had a code name and then the the
code name um also allowed you to do
other things you could be cool yeah yeah
hell yeah yeah you know EO walks in how
it going down my hell yeah good man uh
but and then
uh you would get um familiar with the
cvy
pilant um who were who were flying and
directing air strikes all kinds of
things for you but you you know you knew
who they were uh they knew the one zeros
you know because they're up there
talking to you you know on a regular
basis and sometimes you know that
whatever call sign you had for the
mission would just go away and all of a
a sudden uh they'd be calling me
dynamite and you know we just dro the
call sign it's a lot easier you know I
mean we we had so many assets coming in
that I use my my left hand and my right
pants leg as my information control
center I was constantly writing call
signs down of the next aircraft the next
set of gunships coming in the next set
of f4s coming in I'd write it on there
so I could remember it and Cub's talking
to all this stuff I'm
talking I didn't get to talk to the Air
Force guys very much because our radios
you know didn't match up uh except for
our survival radio but I was talking to
the gunship and telling them you know
where I wanted it um so and and you know
with Pilots all had
names so yeah and you know we did too
and they all have cool cool names too so
yeah you had to get yours oh yeah I I I
haven't I haven't confirmed where tilt
got his name and I asked him about it
but he kind of he kind of snuck around a
little bit I didn't get a solid
answer you know I think some of the
names kind of came about like um fighter
pilot names MH you've done something and
everybody starts to call you that or you
know it's it maybe a name that you had
before you got there and I I think the
best I can determine tilt had the name
tilt before he got there yep and it had
something to do I did get this out of
them it had something to do with pinball
so like when you're playing pinball you
tilt the machine
and so it's usually because you're doing
something nefarious as you're trying to
win so that's what we're thinking from
tilt he was doing something trying to
win trying to beat the game yeah he's
gonna
win uh one thing that's really cool
about this book is you break out at the
end of each section you break out some
of the Lessons Learned or some of the
highlights and this this for this
section here I thought it was really
interesting some of these highlights
that you put together um I boarded a
plane
in a world I had known all my life and
got off a plane in a strange dangerous
Wild West World on steroids with a very
different set of rules it was like
entering another
dimension all of my senses were confused
nothing made sense my circadian rhythm
was 12 hours off death was in the air
you could smell it you could feel
it Bob and I made a decision a lot of
people questioned we volunteered for SOG
we had approached the Event Horizon of a
black hole and were being C inside where
nothing
escapes we were at the elite of the
elite level the best of the best or the
craziest of the
crazy probably the the last one there uh
in the new world I was given a new name
dynamite and sent North on a quest to
hunt down and terminate the
enemy so you show up then it's off to uh
FU by right right
yes and I call it fob now out of
reverence for you and tilt because we
young guys call them fobs right and you
guys call them fob so I'm not trying to
keep it I we're deferring to The Experts
here uh fast forward a little bit
sergeant major Macintosh gave gave us a
briefing on the fob1 compound security
safety rules and general area of
operations then he said everyone would
be going to one zero school so if you
don't know one zero is the people that
are going to lead the teams that's what
they're called everyone would be going
to one zero School a week-long course to
teach us how to lead a SOG team on top
secret missions across southeast Asia
actually he said everyone's going except
me when I asked why I wasn't going the
sergeant major said Lieutenant you are
special forces and Ranger qualified
there are a few things they might teach
you that you haven't done already but
not much you can learn those things from
your team which you will be assigned to
tomorrow afternoon we are putting you to
work so straight Off the Bench into the
into the game
I know you go ahead if I could just say
one one thing about the book um I made
it like a journal because what I was
trying to do uh with the book is to give
people an opportunity to kind of see so
Through The Eyes of a one zero uh
experienced to some degree what I was
experiencing describing it the screw-ups
the the fear the whatever you know that
was going on um and what I did with with
my teams was we did our on after action
review after every Mission we get
together as a team and we're going to
talk about what we did you well what we
didn't do so well what happened uh what
we need to do some extra training on so
I set up postm Mission training for my
teams um you know and one case um it was
being able to throw a h grenade from the
prawn lay it on your belly throw a h
grenade and get it far enough away from
us you know that it's not going to hit
us not hit a tree and have it bounce
back at us because with that team I was
said they didn't seem to be good at that
and what they wanted to do was raise up
if you raise up you're going to get hit
I want you to stay alive um but you got
to use the grenades so that I put in the
air things that I saw I learned and we
started to practice and as you go
through the book you can see how it
progresses across time there were things
I was doing in the beginning that I
discovered that's not the best way to do
that there are better ways and we're
going to do it differently we're going
to I Chang the the load out I changed
the amount of ammunition that people
were carrying most SOG teams um would
have one clay more uh per
individual and some individuals might
not have any Claymores uh on my teams I
went to an soop of you carried three
Claymores per person that's a lot of
extra
weight but if you use those things right
you just Shred the bad guys I used to
set them up I'd like to have seven Daisy
chains on the most likely Avenue of AO
Roach coming into us at night I could
set them all off
simultaneously and when you set off 10
and 12 pounds of C4 the concussion from
that the explosion from that if you're
anywhere close to it it's going to at
least knock you out but when you put
4,900 steel balls in there coming at you
at 4,000 ft a second um if you're
anywhere in that zone it's going to
shred you um so what happens
is the Big Bang people
shredded and NVA would look at that and
say this is different this is not what
we're used to with the sog teams this
guy's a
nutcase but you know they gather the
survivors and they would start again and
I'd have another role of either five or
three Claymores the same way and then
they would say he is crazy for sure and
then you know like other so teams we
would um have some individual Claymores
that we'd have time fuses on um and they
were randomly going off and you never
knew I I changed the load out of frag
grenades from five to
10 if you have a seven-man team you have
70 frag
grenades and you can chunk those things
all night they can't see where they're
coming from and just going off all
around you uh anyway that's a few of the
things that I started doing uh and
putting together an sop you know for my
teams uh in terms of what I wanted them
to carry where it was going to be which
pocket you had the map in which you know
everything if it's you know the middle
of the night and it's raining and it's
dark and he can't see anything and I
need to get ammunition or grenades or
whatever off of your body body I know
where to reach to get it if you need to
get it off of my body you know where it
is um so we we did a a lot of things
like that and I wanted to show that how
we learned and eventually you get into
uh where we were learning about the
enemy and how they react what do they
do and there's really interesting things
I'm won't going into you now but really
interesting things in there uh that I
learned about the enemy you know I I
kind of approached it with a scientific
mind because that's what I was you know
training to be before I got there so I
watched I observed I what if what if we
do this what if we do that uh and why
are they reacting that way what are the
chemical reactions that's going on
that's causing them to do different
things and then we would talk about it
and we'd put that into the training so
anyway yeah the the Lessons Learned I
mean we could probably do a podcast
about each chapter and just cover the
lessons learned from each chapter but
then on top of that like you said you
write this like a
journal and you get to when you're
reading it experience what you're going
through what your thoughts are how it's
impacting you and I think a great
example of that is here um again you're
just checking in you've been there at
fob1 for a day you wake up and I'm going
to go to the book here it says the next
morning I went to the supply room after
breakfast when I got there staff
sergeant Jones the supply sergeant told
me that several SOG team members were
killed a few days earlier and their
personal effects had to be inventoried
by an officer before they could be sent
to their families he took me to a room
with seven duffel bags on the
floor and said dump the bags out one at
a time and go through the contents look
for anything that might be classified
Maps operational pictures or anything
like that if there's any correspondence
read it to see if it says anything
anything about any of the missions if
there are pictures take them out I was
to sterilize their gear it sounded
simple enough I picked up the first
olive drab canvas duffel bag and read
the name stencl in Big White letters on
the outside first lieutenant Raymond C
Stacks I felt like I'd been kicked in
the groin SOG just got real Ray was
Bob's and my friend at Fort Bragg he
left for Vietnam about a month before we
did Ray had been in sog for a month and
I was already inventorying his personal
effects to send home to his family Ry
was a good guy totally dedicated his
special forces in the United States I
had no idea he had volunteered for SOG
and now he was dead killed in action on
a SOG mission in Southeast Asian country
actually it was worse than that he and
his six teammates and fourman air crew
were missing in action their remains
could not be recovered their helicopter
was hit with anti-aircraft fire at an
out itude of 3,000 ft and after falling
like a rock into the jungle canopy poow
it exploded and
burned I quickly looked at the names on
the other duffel bags to see if I knew
anyone
else Gary L Matson Arthur E Bader Gary R
Lebon Michael H mine clouse d Schultz
Samuel K Tumi and Richard A Fitz
before I went before continuing I went
back to staff sergeant Jones and asked
him what these men were doing when they
were killed he said no one there knew it
was classified top secret not even the
fob1 commander
knew going through the personal effects
in each bag became a very personal and
emotional task that caused a bond to
form between me and each hero and to
some degree their
families as I laid the contents of a bag
out on the table I put together a mosaic
of each American Hero's personal life
his wife kids parents plans for the
future dogs family pictures of missed
birthday parties holidays First Steps
first words pictures and kids pictures
the kids had drawn how much time he had
left before going home and small talk
with his wife and
parents all the time hiding the extreme
danger of his
missions when I was going
through staff sergeant Richard Fitz
effects I was struck by a picture of his
small 2-year-old son and the
conversations about him and how much
staff sergeant Fitz missed
him so that's a welcome to SOG situation
Y and uh you know you mentioned in the
book but you end up actually making
contact uh 20 plus years later or sorry
50 years later you end up making contact
with uh Richard Fitz Jr his son who was
two years old when he when his dad was
killed how how did that connection come
about he was he was trying to find out
more about his father so he had put a
post on a
maxg uh Facebook site does anyone know
anything about my father so I saw it um
and responded to it and you know so that
kind of connected us and we decided we
would we would meet at the next um uh
Special Operations reunion not knowing
that it was going to be cancelled
because of uh coid so anyway we put it
off but you know this summer we'll meet
or October we'll meet face to face
outstanding so I mean we had some phone
calls and you know a lot of emails and
stuff back and forth but we haven't had
a chance to meet face to face yet and he
made a a documentary that's called 21
years in a folded flag um I tried I I
did a cursory search for it to see if I
could watch it I haven't found it yet
but I'm sure I just need to get to the
right uh streaming platform or whatever
and I'll be able to find it but uh
definitely interested in checking that
out um but yeah I can't I can't imagine
a a a more serious introduction to your
second day at SOG and you have got to go
through all these guys that were killed
I
mean if that doesn't uh hit you I don't
know what is it um definitely makes it
real I mean and all of a sudden I'm
thinking what did John
say don't volunteer for a s and maybe
there's something to that yeah
uh you get put into uh RT
Alabama and so this is this is now where
you're going to start your your SOG
career
um and you say here and again I'm fast
forward I'm only going to read 5% of
this book but there's so much detail in
here the Lessons Learned we're going to
hit some of it but just get the book I'm
going to fast forward here you say my
first mission with rt Alabama was to
conduct a wire tap on a communication
Line running along a road being used as
a Supply route for North Vietnamese
supplies through La in Cambodia or sorry
through La into South
Vietnam uh and you give your a roster
here the one zero is a guy named deck um
you're the one one so you're the second
in charge Davis is the one two and then
you have your interpreter
Cowboy um who is actually on this
podcast the number 258 so he's your
interpreter and then you have HOA
pointman do your m79 Gunner and uh Quang
is the is the tail gun of rear
security so this is your team that
you're G to be going out with for for
the first time um how was it meeting
that team for the first
time it was uh it was interesting you
know it in the beginning of the book you
see when I when I first encountered a
SOG team uh as I was traveling uh up to
fob4 and it was
it was kind of a surreal experience you
know we're on the
bus I I we're on the bus it's a school
bus it was a SOG bus not just because it
was painted black but because all the
all the windows are shot out the seats
are ripped apart where bullets have hit
it there's probably 200 or more bullet
holes you know in the bus
us and you know the Bob and I are
looking at each other I'm like
man are we even going to get there but
and while we're talking we were also
supposed to pick up a team and these
guys just it was like they just
materialized and there they are and and
they they're coming toward us and then
the the last guy I was looking backwards
the whole time he's walking backwards
and constantly looking for what's going
on and they came up to the
bus and they had all this stuff on uh we
just never seen before I mean they've
got grenades hanging all over them all
types of grenades hanging on them
they've got grenades on their in pouches
you know on their hip they've got
magazines on their hip they've got some
kind of weapon that we hadn't seen
before they had what looked like m79
grenade launchers saw off it was just
big fat pistols and they had those
hanging on them
I mean it's just amazing and everything
was sterile there was no name tags no
insignias no dog tags no vests no
helmets nothing um and they were scared
I'm telling they these are some scary
dudes coming up there yeah you go over
that in the book and they basically tell
you hey if we get contacted because
there was some little uh Ambush choke
point that you had to drive through in
this school bus to get to the fob and so
they said hey if if we get hit you guys
just get down and do what we tell you to
do yeah just get on the floor and do
what we tell you to do if you want to
live yes sir and but when they got on
the bus once you know as they are coming
on the bus they're going to defensive
position everybody had a position on the
bus windows that they were focused on um
anyway they were scared they they made
the hair stand up on the back of your
neck and when we when we got the
fob4 they walked off the bus and we
blinked and they were gone where did
they go how did they do that but so I
had I had seen you know B and I had seen
a team before and we thought man a
couple days we're going to be on one of
those so I go I go meet my new team and
you know it was uh was interesting a
team is supposed to have non indigenous
members and three
Americans most teams didn't have quite
that many of of either type of person
you know just because they get shot up
all the time or killed or whatever um
but normally you would go out with two
or three Americans on the team and every
how many of the uh indid that you wanted
to carry you know based on what the
mission
was so you get linked up with these guys
and um just real quick you you explain a
so Mission you say a so mission was not
just hop on in a hel helicopter fly 30
minutes with uh to a site shoot some bad
guys and fly back it's very complicated
with a lot of moving Parts all these
assets were totally focused on getting
the team inserted to the into the area
of operations supporting it while it
accomplished this Mission and getting
the team back out safely as as possible
I was quite impressed we were using what
I found to be our standard fob1 Mission
package for insertion and instraction so
so what you're pointing out here is is
that yeah there's going to be what seven
eight n guys on the ground with a lot of
Firepower for a team that big but the
package that's supporting you is huge
it's a huge package so you have and you
go through it here I'll go through it
briefly but you have an Airborne
Battlefield command and control center
so that's you know a big
electronic uh host elect uh a a a ec130
basically it's an aircraft with a bunch
of electronics in it they can
communicate well then you have the the
cvy aircraft
which is a Forward Air controller into
cvy usually in those the cvy Riders are
SOG guys that have
now moved up into the aircraft to
support from the sky those guys do an
incredible uh amount of work like the
they're like that it's the opposite of
what the Marine Corps has the Marine
Corps takes a takes a fighter pilot and
puts him on the ground for their anglio
units like Dave Burke that's what he did
good deal Dave this is the opposite yeah
good deal Dave this is the opposite they
take a saw guy and put him in the sky so
it it's pretty unique um then you have
the F4 Phantoms then you have the A1
skyraiders then you have the cobras and
then you have the lift ships which are
which are King Beast so you have this
massive package that's going out that's
going to be able to support you guys
from the sky uh pretty incredible it's
also pretty incredible that they were
able to keep SOG so compartmentalized
even though there's all these aircraft
that are going out and flying these
missions that's pretty impressive mhm I
don't know how they did that cuz these
Pilots are going back hitting the bar
having some beers I mean how could you
not come back if you're a a Skyraider
pilot or a cobra pilot or you know one
of these Hues that's going in and
distracting guys and how can you not go
back and say I just got back from
Cambodia and my freaking aircraft's full
of bullet holes right
now well they you know you usually they
came from the same unit so they were
going back to their little group who
were flying these particular Miss
they were being pulled out uh on a
regular basis to go out and fly these
missions got so they could talk to each
other when they went back got it um but
they'd get a new door gunner or
something every once in a while and he's
sitting there he didn't know where
they're going you I just go where the
the chopper goes and he's sitting there
and then he sees this River and he's
saying H I think that's the
Border I think we're we're headed
straight for LA or Cambodia or whatever
and you know their faces kind of light
up and they get brief when they get back
don't you dare tell anybody we want to
cross that
River so uh fast forward a little bit
here the flight out as the UI started to
wind up I could also hear the high pitch
wine of the cobras revving up about 200
meters from us the launch site became
very noisy and the smell of
jp4 was strong this excitement was
building the excitement was building as
the noise kept increasing my heart rate
was steadily increasing my mouth was
getting dry this was exhilarating we had
gone over this part of the mission many
times but it's different when you're
sitting in the middle of the
multi-dimensional event with all the
sights sounds smells taste adrenaline
cortisol butterflies in the stomach a
vibrating aircraft starting to lift off
the ground for your first SOG
Mission and I was thinking about this
yesterday this wasn't just your first
SOG Mission this was your first mission
mission
right
yeah
that's
ridiculous that's crazy uh I had the I
had like a very nice gentle Glide slope
going into combat operations as a matter
of fact when I got to Iraq there was one
of my buddies who was my who's going to
be my task unit senior enlisted guy he'd
been there for a while he'd been there
for like a
month and when we got there he like spun
up some little Mission we were going to
go outside the wire and we were going to
go do some vehicle addiction it was I'm
not saying he made it up but he kind of
made it up just to kind of get just get
me my platoon get us outside the wire
drive around get some of the you know
get some of the nerves out so that was
sort of our our
intro and then you know we just started
doing a little bit more and a little bit
more and a little bit more but and you
do you know you get more used to it
you're like okay I'm you shake off some
of those nerves but you're going on your
first mission and it's a freaking SOG
Mission that's kind of crazy it was
crazy it it would have been even crazier
if I had had any idea about what was
going to happen I mean I really thought
you know we're going to go out here get
on the ground we're going to run around
do this wire tap we'll probably shoot a
couple of guys before we come back and
you know we once we're in contact we'll
get shot at some but you know we'll
we'll come back not a big
deal so it didn't quite go like that no
I'm going to go to the book here we were
slowly approaching the insertion hole
flying with the skids dragging across
the jungle canopy the hole looked small
the aircraft vibrated and as we
literally dropped straight down into the
bomb
crater the pilot was trying not to clip
the trees as we were setting down it was
just getting dark Davis and I were on
the skid we rapidly scann the jungle
around the crater but it was too dark
and the vegetation was too thick to see
into the jungle our descent stopped we
were still about 6 ft above the crater
and we were going to have to jump into
the bomb crater I thought it was a long
jump carrying 95 pounds of weight I knew
I just had to suck it up and jump Davis
and I bent our knees to jump and as we
did I saw an NVA Soldier pop up on my
right about 10 feet off to the side with
an AK-47 pointed at me instantly instead
of jumping I pushed up and back to the
edge of the helicopter floor just as I
jumped up the soldier opened fire with
his AK-47 the bullets came right across
where my legs had been half a second
before and hit Davis in the legs he
screamed and yelled I'm hit I'm hit help
as his legs collapsed and started to
fall the the fireball coming out of the
AK-47 barrel was blinding and the sound
was deafening simultaneously the whole
jungle lit up around us and made an
unbelievably loud roar as 20 to 30 NVA
opened fire on automatic at once I
grabbed the back of Davis's lbe harness
with my left hand and use my right hand
to put a half a magazine on Full Auto
into the NVA soldier who was less than
10 ft away the impact of the rounds
ripped him apart and blood splattered on
me as he went down aided by adrenaline
and cortisol I managed to jerk Davis up
onto the floor of the helicopter blood
was going everywhere then I saw the
muzzle flashes right in front of me
there was nothing but air between me and
the NVA who was shooting at me from 20
to 30 feet away I was totally exposed I
could be seen I could be hit I could be
killed everyone in the aircraft was
returning fire the two door Gunners with
their M60 machine guns and the team
members two of whom were using me as
cover and one firing on each side of my
head their car 15 muzzles were so close
I was getting powder burns from the
muzzle flashes my ears began to go numb
and I knew I was going to lose my
bearing my hearing hot brass was going
all over me in the floor of the
helicopter and the floor on my side was
covered with blood that was getting
deeper hundreds of bullets were coming
at us traveling faster than the speed of
sound I heard them crack as they passed
through the cargo compartment of or by
the helicopter some were green tracers I
could actually see them coming out of
the dark jungle vegetation and trees I
tried to lean back to present a smaller
Target I heard the metallic clangs of
bullets hitting the helicopter crap
we're going down Davis was in pain
rolling on the floor and screaming blood
continued to run on the floor I put the
other half of the magazine into the
muzzle flashes coming from the treeon
directly in front of me and saw the NVA
Soldier fall out hit the ground hard I
heard myself say that's twoo now my
magazine was empty we were in a
full-fledged Ambush now all the way
around us our two go Cobra gun ships had
open fire with their Min guns each
firing 4,000 rounds a minute it looked
like two hoses were being were spraying
red water all around us every fifth
bullet was a tracer but when they were
coming that fast all you could see was
red the bullets were ricocheting off
trees rocks in the ground friendly
bullets were going in all directions the
helicopter vibrated violently as the
pilot tried to lift us out of the bomb
crater he had not planned to lift off
with all that all of us still on board
some of the bullets were still were
hitting trees and Limbs and flying off
and some of the trees were falling rocks
were being hit sending fragments flying
everything was so loud the second set of
cobras followed right behind the first
two firing Min guns and 40mm grenades
explosions went off all around us the
air was full of shrapnel smoke and the
smell of gunpowder and burned jp4 the
team was shooting door Gunners were
shooting the Cobras were shooting the
NVA were shooting determined to take our
helicopter down I was have having
trouble getting the magazine out of my
pouch it appeared to be stuck and my
fingers were slick with all the blood on
them I finally got out a magazine then
had trouble getting it in the magazine
well of my car5 I could see hundreds and
hundreds of bullets and green NVA
tracers coming at the aircraft I
realized the stress level had caused me
to lose most of my fine motor skills and
B bullets were coming at me still I got
the magazine in and re-engaged the enemy
I had a conversation going in the back
of my head while I kept shooting I'm not
happy with this first mission I'm going
to die in the first 15 seconds I spent
two years training for this what kind of
deal is this I came over here to do
something this is crazy I got another
magazine out of the pouch and sent it
into my car
15 I shot at the muzzle flashes in front
of me they would go out after I put four
or five round burst on them and I saw
NVA fall from trees my magazines were
coming out of the pouch and into my car
15 much easier now and I racked up some
more kills I saw tracers and heard
screams coming out of the Jungle from
wounded and dying NVA then suddenly a
blast wave followed by a loud boom came
across and almost knocked the helicopter
into the trees it was followed by
several more with less intensity all of
us in the helicopter were temporarily
stunned from the concussions and
deafened by the loud explosions the
hooches I had seen on the other side of
the ridgel line turned out to be tanks
camouflaged with straw and the A1 Sky
Raiders were dropping 250 bound pound
bombs on them this added significantly
to the noise and Chaos the a1s were also
receiving anti-aircraft fire and they
engaged those positions too our
helicopter started to vibrate violently
because the pilot was trying to climb
out of that little hole in the canopy
jungle in the jungle canopy at least we
were trying to start up but the
helicopter was taking hits and the
Cobras were making more runs finally we
actually lifted out of the bomb crater
as we did the NVA shifted their fire
following us up as we went I was
learning that the NVA were an incredibly
determined enemy they would not quit I
saw a smoke grenade in the crater
spewing red smoke the red smoke meant
there were no good guys left on the LZ
all aircraft were cleared hot for the LZ
as we pulled away from the opening and
into the canopy the NVA fire stopped
because the cobras blasted the whole
Ambush site with
rockets the a1s came in with the big
stuff and the cobras finished their last
run it was an amazing fireworks show
they destroyed the whole area to include
six tanks as we started to fly away I
looked across at staff sergeant deck who
was sitting on the other side he looked
across he looked across at me with a big
grin on his face and gave me an
enthusiastic thumbs up I thought to
myself look at this guy he's so excited
he thought this was the coolest thing
but man they almost got us
all it was my time it was my first time
to experience a level of fear that I
didn't know existed many times I tried I
tried to imagine what it would be like
when people started shooting at me of
course I knew it would be a little
anxious but I had no clue until I
experienced it there was no way I could
even imagine the level of fear like that
fortunately I was able to manage the
fear so I could still shoot I did not
let fear stop me from returning fire and
doing what I had to do but it scared
me welcome to SOG
yeah again I mean I'm hitting the
highlights of that uh which that's
obviously it's a short Mission I mean
that whole how that whole thing probably
took three minutes or
something um you go and hear some firsts
this is your first mission first time in
combat first time being ambushed first
enemy kills unbelievable fear adrenaline
cortis so so high I couldn't breathe but
I could shoot in the back of my head I
thought I was going to die on my first
mission not happy about that to have so
many bullets coming at me from every
direction and not get hit first time
saving an American teammate's Life blood
and hot brass everywhere high frequency
hearing loss a lot temporary and some
permanent powder burns on my face earned
my combat infantryman's badge discovered
firsthand what stress does to my fine
motor
coordination lot going on you learned a
lot even in those 3
minutes yeah there was a lot uh lot
happening a lot you know to
process but um I mean it was a good
experience because I survived
lived but you
know going back and processing that you
know on on my own you know to start with
um
it was good for me to realize when the
target shoot back everything
changes and a lot of what what I was
doing it do didn't work in that
situation I couldn't get the magazine
out of the pouch because you know the
the rule was you take a a canteen pouch
and you cram six 20 round magazines in
there so you had one pounce here with
six magazines the problem is there and
they tight mhm if your hands are like
this you can reach in there and grab it
and pull it out but when you have blood
on your hands your hands slick you
couldn't get a hold of it so the next
day after thinking through
that excuse me after thinking through
that I'll put a cord on it piece of
parachute cord tape duct tape it onto
the center one with a little loop I can
hook my finger in because once the first
one comes out the rest of them easy to
get the rest of them out so just little
things little techniques that make all a
difference in the world that you don't
think about when you're out training and
rehearsing and practicing because you
don't have any blood on
you it's just like when the target shoot
back it changes everything blood changes
everything so I'm riding all this stuff
down uh so that I can make changes you
know when I get my team I can tell
here's how we're going to do things
mhm um you have here additional Lessons
Learned and I put a star by a bunch of
these um whatever I plan I will have to
adapt war is not predictable the only
predictability was that the plan will
have to be adapted and I have to be able
to adapt on the
Fly the enemy does not normally get a
seat at the mission planning table thus
they don't know how they're supposed to
act during the mission they tend to mess
things up
they do every
time I must control and manage my
fear luck always plays a role in
combat don't stop shooting a very high
volume return of fire is your best
chance of survival focus on the
immediate situation too late to ask who
is supposed to drain the swamp when
you're up to your armpits and
alligators must be able to do everything
in the dark and Under
Fire speed of execu and accuracy are
critical know your people their weapons
and their actions Under Fire when you
select them how to distribute them know
how the enemy will will react to your
presence and actions mindset is critical
to success timing is everything you are
part of a team practice practice and
practice more I must get better every
time I do
something and I need to fix my magazines
so they're easy to retrieve even under
the stress with a bloody hand attach a
cord loop on the middle one so there you
go uh then you had a list of Leadership
Lessons never underestimate luck good or
bad that always that always will send up
a warning sign to me when I'd be looking
at a mission a plan for a mission and
you could see that there was some things
that were going to have to
go in the way of the platoon like well
you know we we're hoping for this and
it'll probably be that and as soon as
you stack a couple of those things up
like it ain't going to work it ain't
going to work uh leadership lesson I'm
not as good as I think I am I can get
injured a lot of ways besides getting
hit with a
bullet nothing will go as planned you
can see you learn that lesson pretty
hard uh stress changes everything never
forget that I that I did it as part of a
team I can always do more than I think I
can which is weird too you got I'm not
as good as I think I am but I can always
do more than I think I
can uh if I'm doing my job as a leader I
am going to get hit
communication is my lifeline know my
people know my enemy timing is
everything down to the fraction of a
second everyone must know the one Zero's
Commander
intent sometimes everyone must perform
on their
own combat is very
loud uh I'm not out of danger until we
get back to the fob hence the saying fui
is all right
um exposure and experience prepare me
for more complex learning it's difficult
to learn calculus before learning basic
math knowledge and learning occur in
layers and then you have a I have to
throw this one in here never talked to
Jack Daniels before giving your boss
feedback about how ug because you went
in for a debrief you had some you had a
few beverages in you probably didn't do
the most uh politically correct debrief
with your
boss you know honestly I was thinking
about this though this your first
mission right and you got to get in get
out get to shoot get to get shot at and
it all happened in three minutes it's
not a bad first SOG Mission could have
been worse
yes and I don't know Sergeant deck had a
recommendation for
me I I asked him when we got got back to
Long site I said you know while we were
in there how many magazines did you
empty you know during that couple of
minutes or so that we were down the
hole and and he said you know I I
emptied five I was almost through with
my sixth one I threw two frag grenades
and a smoke
grenade and I'm thinking wow and then he
said I'm going to tell you something
Lieutenant if you don't learn to change
magazine faster when people are shooting
at you you're going to
die I said yeah I think you're right but
you I thought I would pretty fast but um
obviously I got to get faster you know
you you can't have those breaks you know
and shooting not not when you're that
close and that many of them you know
what I had seen what you saw on cowboy
movies and you saw on some army movies
police movies
is you know you shoot at me I get down
behind the Rock and when you and then
you stop shooting and you get behind the
Rock and I get up and I shoot and that's
not the way it is no I mean you know you
might get down to reload or something
but Eko still shooting at me that's the
way it's supposed to be you know a dozen
other guys over here still shooting they
can't even see me they just hear you
know my gun firing so they know about
where I am and they're shooting at me
and they can't even see me so there's no
break you I mean someone's always
shooting at you there's never just one
enemy that's the way it's supposed to
be
um all right fast forward again just get
the book there's so much in here I'm G
to fast forward a little bit um this is
Mission Number Two Al RT Alabama mission
number two RT Alabama's next mission was
to find and destroy a battalion sized
NVA element moving through Northern LA
to South Vietnam our eight-man uh RT
would be looking for a f for 500 NVA
soldiers so this is you know this is SOG
right you're go you're G to take eight
guys you're g go find a battalion of 500
plus
guys and I you know I figured I mean it
should be pretty easy to find them I
mean if there's 500 of them it it can't
be that hard to do now surviving you
know is a different story but I was
pretty excited because I thought I'm
going to learn how to do this I mean
this is what SOG does and this is a a
relatively small group that we've been
tasked to go out and find and and
Destroy so are you getting Mission
guidance or debriefs from the other SOG
teams that are with you guys at this fob
we get some most most of it takes place
in the club in the bar
yeah and you know it was it was like a
training center so you go in there and
you that's that's when you get a chance
to talk to some of the other one zero
some of the other operators you know
because we're just passing each other in
the dark I mean tilt tilt and I we're at
fob1
together we'd wave every once in a while
as we'd pass each other in the dark we
we both went to uh dang together and ran
missions out of there together we knew
each other but and we'd see each other
in the Club every once in a while but we
didn't have time for a relationship
because you know we were always on the
move going out to the field practicing
whatever so yeah you would think that uh
just being able to communicate with the
guys I mean this is now going to be your
second mission the lessons learned that
they could pass on to you but of course
you got deck and he's more
experienced um and I had there was a an
NCO in in the club um that I met and
he kind of took me under his wing and
you know he would tell me things
like all right you listen to what I'm
going to tell you
lieutenant never
ever shoot an NBAA one
time
always three or four times and if he
Twitches three or four more times
because you can't believe how many SOG
guys have been killed by dead
NVA you have to take them out the person
that shoots first it's got the highest
chance of survival I mean I mean he had
a list of things like that you know that
he would share to me with me when we
would see each other and there just you
know I could ask him you know about
different techniques different
things yeah that's the kind of feedback
you want um and that's obviously some
good information for you to have
so for for this Mission you know again
in the book you cover the plan you cover
the preparation you know your thought
process and then you get to the insert
you talk through the insertion and then
of course um we get to the point where
you all are contacted and and now it's
on um I'm going to fast forward here to
the book The Fighting was fierce and we
were carrying Quang so Quang had already
been wounded I also got to see Cowboy In
Action he was a real Warrior no fear he
worked with me fighting a delaying
action at the rear of the team slowing
down the NVA he had experience using
Claymores with time fuses and a great
Instinct for the way the NVA moved
against us Cowboys experience and
courage made our Claymores and C4
charges more effective when we you guys
are trying to get out of here um I I
fast forward to pass that part but when
we got about a 100 meters from the LZ
all hell broke loose from our front
there were 30 to 40 NVA weight in on us
now we were between two groups so you're
getting chased by a group and now you
got a group in front of us the group
from from the LZ open fire with a heavy
barrage from AK-47s machine guns and
RPGs they assaulted and began trying to
maneuver around our flanks there were
several loud booms one of them hitting
me with concussion mud and other debris
some of which went in my eyes I was
having trouble seeing my Ruck and radio
were hit with shrapnel from one of the
b40 Rockets the radio looked bad but
still worked the small wooden box of
blasting caps was hit but not penetrated
some of the C4 was hit but that was not
a big deal deck called me to his
position he wanted the a1s to put their
20mm fire on the NVA to our front we
were about to be crushed the first A1
gun run got the nv's attention and
stopped their assault they did not
expect the devastation of the 20 mm the
second A1 gun run made them start to
scatter the cobras arrived on site and
worked above and below us with rockets
Min guns and 40 mm we continued to fight
our way to the edge of the LZ and saw 20
to 30 NVA bodies scattered around some
of them were still alive and had to be
terminated we were not in a position to
take prisoners cvy said the extraction
ship was a UI and wanted smoke Jones
threw a purple smoke grenade on the edge
of the LZ the huie identified purple
deck got everyone ready to dash to the
chopper on his command we also turned
our Bush Hats inside out so the bright
orange vs7 panel sewn to the inside
would make us identifi to identifiable
to the door Gunners we didn't want to be
mistaken for an NVA trying to get to the
chopper which the NVA sometimes tried
deck went to the left side of the
chopper with HOA do and the wounded
Quang Jones cowboy and I took the
wounded Quan to the right side I climbed
on just before deck as the chopper was
lifting off the door Gunners and all
team members not wounded return fire
from the chopper as we got to 20 ft in
the air deck and I both threw a red
smoke grenade to signal that the LZ and
surrounding areas were cleared hot
meaning anyone on the ground was a bad
guy cvy was free to destroy everything
there we continued to receive fire as we
climbed out I heard a few metallic
clangs as the chopper took hits I looked
over at deck he gave me his
characteristic big smile and a thumbs up
as I was about as I began to give
medical attention to Quang and Quan I
thought wow what an adrenaline rush I
now had a better understanding of the
emotions deck was experiencing while he
when he would give me a big smile and
thumbs up as we flew away I saw and
heard our air assets air assets pounding
the crap out of the bad guys we had
found the NVA Battalion and Reign death
and destruction down on them our team
had also taken out a large number of
them on the ground I continued to be
amazed how at how tough and deadly our
little guys were in a firefight after a
short prayer I settled back down for the
ride yeah you you mentioned earlier that
you had cowboy on one of the the podcast
and I I was I was watching that and he
he said y'all were talking about a
contact and he said yeah I I catch
bullet and and I could see your face and
his and you were you were kind of
looking at him like what and he said I
catch
bullet right here and then you could see
you know his hand was just a big scar on
inside and then he said and I catch one
here and I
catch he was he was a hard dude yeah
yeah and and and again like so that's
your second mission and it's total maam
I mean I I read a small portion of it
you you're you're it's total
manam how did you feel as far as your
pro your your internal processor on that
one compared to the first one I had I
felt that I I knew a lot more about what
was going on uh I knew what to expect
you know fear wise I knew it was going
to mess some things up uh but I was also
learning watching what they were doing
watching what cowboy was doing uh there
were some conversations with deck um you
know where pman told
deck noo too too many VC mhm deck said
go no
VC and you know I'm I'm hearing this
conversation you know the p man might
know what he's talking about so deck
said no you know so we stood up and we
started go and um you know it's kind of
like one of those horror movies where
you expect leather face to jump out from
behind a tree with a chainsaw and start
sewing arms off and stuff because the p
man was right but deck said no we're
we're going to go and it made me wonder
what I mean what did what do deck
know that no one else knew we all heard
the same sounds why did deck decide it
wasn't VC they call them VC the
NBA and and then later in that mission
it happened again
and deck said
okay not this
um yeah that's NBAA this time but you
know so spending some time with him when
I got back and said help me understand
what what did you hear that was
different you know how did you know um
that it wasn't right or it was right or
whatever so trying to learn trying to
pick his brain uh every time we went out
see what I could learn and you know one
thing I was getting to do is I was
carrying the radio so I was having most
of the conversations with with cubby and
and starting to have conversations with
the
gunships and and you can see how it
progresses in the book to somebody who
you know I I knew i' to call artillery I
done all of that stuff you know in
training but I never talked to a cubby
before I didn't know about working
gunships I didn't know all this stuff
but I was starting to learn each Mission
we went out I would you know doing that
more and more um and and learning what
the NBA were doing what they expected
from us and how they
reacted so I'm I'm starting to lay this
stuff out put it together um and in the
first time uh well this this well first
time part of the Intel debriefing soon
as we got back you that wasn't all that
Pleasant either um yeah you put you put
that in the book and they're asking you
questions well how many weapons did you
see you're like a freaking lot of
them and but you know so how many times
did they shoot at you there's 30 of them
firing on automatic I don't know you
know I was too busy shooting back at
them yeah and you know anyway uh I was
told that I needed to change my attitude
but
but that was part of the learning
experience for me because I discovered
later that if I
listen I might not know how many bullets
were
coming but I could easily distinguish
the difference between an AK-47 and an
RPD and if I hear that RPD that's
telling me if they've got a machine gun
with them oh that's a bigger group this
is not four or five guys just out there
stumbling through the woods now we got a
larger group were there two of them do
they have RPGs you know so as I start to
hear these other sounds and listen to
how they move it tells me what size
Force we're up against what we need to
do and and you you can see how all that
stuff worked into you know strategy you
know adapt yeah like we're talking
before I got to the point where I knew
when my foot stepped off the skid I
would have to start adapting whatever
plan we have you know because it wasn't
going to be exactly like we had
planned so yeah um there's a couple
things I was thinking is I I think freef
fall parachuting is such a good example
because everyone that you talk to
experiences this your first freef fall
like my first freef fall what do you
what did you see on your first freef
fall you see like the sky the ultim sky
altim aler and put parachute worked like
that's all you see you you don't know
you know and then even the next jump you
see a little bit more and then 10 jumps
in you're like oh I can see the ocean I
can see the mountains you're kind of you
you adapt to it and you're your field
the vision opens up so much more and
that's what you can see in the book this
this idea that you're talking about with
the air
assets um by the end of the book you're
like a conductor of a or of a symphony
of Destruction and you're calling in the
aircraft they're coming in from
different places you're setting them up
this one first this one second this one
third come back and hit him again a
little further over there like you
you're you can tell you've gotten really
good at it which is you can see it again
you know this is just experience and
then um yeah what you say about the
being adaptable I got asked a little
while ago you know if we if you were the
commander and you were going into the
war in uh they were saying oh China
invited Taiwan what would you do what
would your attitude be if you were going
on the ground and I said my my the most
important thing to me would be keeping
an open mind and everyone kind of looked
at me like what kind of answer is that I
said because I don't know what the enem
is going to do I don't know we sure we
we're going to predict some things but I
don't know what they're going to do I
don't actually know what all my guys are
going to do I have a pretty good idea
I'm going to land maybe I can guess 80
90% what my guys are going to do maybe I
can guess 50% of what the enemy's going
to do but that means there's a whole lot
of margin for things are going to change
so my attitude was always keep an open
mind what what's going on don't get
stuck in the plan don't get stuck in
believing anything that you see right in
front of you right now because things
are going to change and that's clearly
clearly what you had to do as soon as
you stepped off that helicopter skid
every time all right where are we at
how's this going to go uh very good
Lessons Learned for anybody in any in
anything
um fast forward a little bit RT Alabama
mission three
and this is an operation uh after a day
of rest we were assigned another mission
with a short prep time our mission was
to locate and contaminate an NVA
ammunition cache near a major Supply
route in the eastern part of the Dem
military rise zone between South and
North Vietnam using eldest son also
called exploding ammunition Italian
green and Bine uh po Bean so this is an
this is a a a sort of a scops operation
that was happening where the US military
would take mortar rounds and they would
rig those mortar rounds so that when you
dropped it into the mortar tube they'd
blow up and they do it with bullets
they'd do it with everything and it's
just a little psychological operation
that actually also interferes with
whatever operations happened at the time
and so they would take these um
manipulated ammunition this exploding
ammunition and go and plant it so that
was your tasking on this
Mission um and then you say
this I'm going to go to the book
unfortunately two weeks prior on 30
November 1968 an eldest son team's
helicopter was hit with 37 mm
anti-aircraft fire and fell like a rock
to the Jungle canopy 3,000 ft below
exploded and burned the air crew and
seven so team members died that day a
bright light mission mission to recover
a missing team or missing members was
not attempted because of the location
and the number of NVA in the area I was
shocked when he shared this information
I realized that I had inventoried the
personal effects of these SOG Heroes
including my friend Ray Stax on my
second day at
fob1 this small piece of so of SOG had
come full circle in a week I would be
inserted as part of a team to complete
their
mission
that can't feel real
comfortable right I mean that just that
can't feel real comfortable the last
group that went in to do this mission
that you're go going on they all died
you happen to be and this was only three
weeks prior four weeks prior something
like that maybe a little over a
month fast forward a little bit I'm
going to take you into the mission here
um ba basically going through the insert
real quick you guys as you insert you
guys get
gassed with cs gas and you guys didn't
have your masks with you and the NVA
opens fire on you
um you know you bring in the cobras they
they go in they uh they put down this
they kill a bunch of them you you decide
to continue Mission and and that's what
you do you continue the mission you head
to the storage area um you find the the
the the cash that you're supposed to mix
in these these rounds and that's what
you do
um you make it to the LZ and you say I
give uh gave cvia Roger that Chopper
comes in the team boarded quickly and we
were off no shots fired I saw deck turn
his head to the side quickly gave him a
thumbs up and a smile and he laughed so
it's a pretty smooth operation
probably the rare smooth operation but
what really upsets people in general
about that mission
was there was a
dog at T
cash and you killed the dog yeah I had
to shoot the dog yeah yeah people don't
like that you killed several hundred
they don't NVA on the they don't care
about the NVA but when you shoot a dog
you know
yeah it's it's not easy shooting dogs
yeah they can they can take more hits
than you think they can and then they
make a bunch of noise yeah so this big
clandestine idea that you have oh we're
just going to shoot this dog with a
suppressed uh
MP5 then the
things and then what happens to all the
other dogs they they want to know what's
going on yeah uh the the dogs dogs are
great for defense you know they they
just any kind of dog that bark they're
going to bark they're going to go crazy
it's hard to silence them yeah so I
didn't realize that we had a touchy
subject there on the killing of the
dog uh you had some cool Lessons Learned
though uh the first group of NVA that
ran from us we were very aggressive
hunted them down and terminated them
they were guards they were not normal
NVA Warriors we fought so you hit some
like rear Echelon yeah their their
mission was um to help with the
transportation kind of place a little
security around the cachets help rebuild
the roads do things they were not the
hardcore North Vietnamese SOG hunter
killer teams so yeah it was like chasing
rabbits you know we just chase them down
and terminate
them you and and that's when you know
when deck and I talked us we got a time
I mean it didn't matter if they knew the
plan or not or what they were supposed
to do they're gone we still have time to
get down there and plant the stuff and
do a night
extraction uh post Mission train you
detail so much stuff in the book one of
the things that you I'm going to mention
here what you mention on the other ones
too but this one post Mission training
continue Fitness training for the most
part the team did not like or want to do
it I began to camouflage it into the
mission pre-training by having the team
carry their Loadout weight for most of
our training I found it to be very I
found them to be very strong for their
size they' been carrying a similar
weight for a long time we continue to
work so that was interesting like just
realizing cuz you were what you weighed
a buck 40 yeah and sometimes your gear
was approaching 100
pounds yeah I mean even I mean the first
the first time I actually started doing
something carrying the full load out I
mean it was cutting my shoulders yeah I
mean I I had to stren I was very strong
coming in because I you know i' done all
kind of stuff before I got there um but
my shoulders were not prepared to have
all that weight pulling down on them
yeah you know but I watched them and I
thought you know I'm going to up
the
Claymores fried grenades and things like
that so they're going to have to carry
more weight than what they've been
caring we need to build some strength
up but the the concept and I here we're
going to
exercise that did not go over that did
not go over at
all uh well you did a good job
camouflaging it right hey just wear your
gear wear your full load out that type
of thing um we continued working on I
ads and standard operating
procedures the team members were not
happy about the eating and hydration
procedures but did it anyways what was
that
about I wanted to make sure that they
didn't get dehydrated out on the
missions so we would start like 3 days
before they had to drink a lot more
water they had to do do more
electrolytes things like that before we
went out I gradually excuse me across
time started changing what they were
allowed to
eat because even
though North Vietnamese and South
Vietnamese were similar at similar kinds
of things that were a little
different um and how they ate it was a
little different
so I could smell the North Vietnamese I
could smell the South ones too but I
could tell the
difference because they had different
different spices but that meant they
could they could do the same thing to us
if the wind was coming from behind us
they would get a whol of spices that
they didn't normally eat and you know
eventually he's like where did that come
from there's somebody out there probably
South Vietnamese so we started doing
things like that eventually we got to
the point where uh no one was allowed to
use soap when they took a shower the
last three days so no shaving cream no
soap no anything that was going to
create an
odor um I mean even got to the point
where I I just told I said I want your
poop to smell like North Vietnamese poop
you know so we're going to change what
we eat you know we want to smell like
them we we want to do there's a lot of
things we want to do is and over in the
book more we get into where I started
teaching them uh how to be invisible and
invisibility I won't go into it here but
invisibility is a lot more
than I camouflage or I be careful how I
move invisibility takes in all the
senses you have you have to hide all of
the you know smell taste sound
everything how you move got into you
know people tended to want to take their
weapon and turn the weapon and sweep
back and forth like that when you go
deer
hunting how do you see that buck when
he's
coming in the hardest direction to see
someone coming at you is when they
coming directly at you but even though
the buck might be walking directly at
you what they tend to do is turn their
head and look and when they
do you know with with the coloration and
everything it makes it easier to see
them when coming at you the same with
you you start turning your head I'll see
the movement even if you're coming
straight at me and particularly if
you're moving the weapon and we started
training with um Point
shooting I mean I and I was on a p
podcast with a guy a tier one operator
from Canada um a few days ago and I was
talking about this and I said I I don't
aim you know if I'm looking at it that's
where the bullet's going to go and he
just oh geez that's exactly it he said I
don't even think about the gun I'm
looking right where I want that bullet
to hit and I pull the tri and that's
where it goes because I've done it so
much you know in training and just shoot
and shoot and shoot it's going to be
where I'm looking and I'm not swerving
the gun around except at the last second
um so I'm teaching the p
man look straight ahead with his with
his head move your eyes they're not
going to see your eyes they'll see your
face or head if you start
turning um so just a lot of things like
that that we started put in with the
teams yeah you also say you spent uh
time talking about and training to be
more aggressive then is that based on
the fact that these NVA ran for from you
and you felt like if you get more
aggressive you might be able to get the
upper yeah and I I heard some other
teams talking about um that they were in
contact and they didn't realize how many
they were up against and they went after
them uh and and you heard them say uh
they started to run from
us and then they realized you know just
a handful of us and they stopped and
came back at us and and they had their
buddies that came with them so I you
know okay they're they're human they
don't want to
die but if we generate fire superiority
you know you always talk fire
superiority and you you gain fire
superiority and you're coming after them
in a aggressive Manner and if I use the
the other thing that we talked about
about listening what what am I hearing
over there how many people are returning
fire and what kind of weapons are they
using is this a small enough group that
we can go after and
terminate um and create a lot of damage
or do we need to stop and you know start
thinking about uh getting away you know
plus I'm going to do that anyway I tght
all the guys if you hit I want to hear
you say in English hit hit hit to let me
know you're still alive and you're hit
and I have some idea of where you are
and we're g to we're going to stop going
backwards now we're going to come
forward to the degree that we can and
get
you you know so um you know doing that
kind of training and and they would back
off from us
and there is a place where we actually
crawled up and listened to an NVA train
train in class where they were teaching
this is how you go after so
teams when you encounter a SOG
team they're immediately going to return
fire and break contact they're going to
run you know so you can assault and go
after them because they're running
trying to get away from
you and that's yeah you you come after
us Watch What Happens yeah you got full
sections in here too about you know as
you started to
adapt to the jungle and and you know you
you go through a whole section and I
forget where it is but you go through a
whole section you're talking about what
you're actually doing the protocol that
you had when you would sit down after
you got off the
helicopter how you would L the protocol
you use to
listen and you know some of nights it's
pitch black the only thing you have the
only sense that that that matters is
you're hearing and you'd break the world
around you into quadrants and you'd pay
attention to the sounds coming out of
each particular I mean it's pretty
fascinating and it shows me and it shows
anyone how completely focused you guys
were on taking every advantage of
everything you could even making a uh a
sense that we all kind of take for
granted but we don't really hone in on
when that's your only sense it's all you
got you're going to figure out how to
use it even
better um
fast forward a little bit here I'm going
to go to Mission four Christmas Road
interdiction uh this one you you were
set to launch on the 23rd of December
plan to stay at least through the 27th
this meant we would be deep inside LA
and near large concentrations of enemy
on Christmas Day I learned that the
ceasefire did not cover countries
outside the two vietnams no Christmas
turkey dinner this year our mission was
to make sure that the NVA in our area of
operation did not get a free day we were
to move to an observation point where we
could observe and interdict Supply
traffic on a major shipping route from
La into South
Vietnam so that's what you're going to
do for Christmas Merry
Christmas and you know for each one of
these you would go through and you go
through it in the book you know you go
through the training cycle that you're
going to do how you prep for it you do a
visual reconnaissance which means you're
going to get in an aircraft like a small
little observation aircraft like an ov1
you're going to go and you're going to
fly around in that area obviously you're
not going to burn it but you'll go fly
around seven different areas one of them
is going to be the target area you'll
you'll observe it from there take a look
at it kind of get eyes
on um and then you roll out you roll on
this operations
um you have a good a good section here
this is where you get get out on a
there's a snake out there that one of
your one of your little people uh rolled
up on and gave the signal for a snake so
this got everyone a little bit
paranoid um I'm going to fast forward a
little bit to the day two of this
operation as daylight dawned on
Christmas Eve all team members were
alert and listening for the enemy we
fast forward we'd been moving about 20
minutes and we heard the Clack of two
bamboo sticks hit together approximately
200 100 m down the Ridge and off to the
East 40 seconds later we heard a
response clack that seemed to be the
same distance but on the west side of
the ridge we had two trackers leading an
NVA group up the ridge looking for us
and attempting to flush us out of hiding
so they could find us this was not a
good sign to make it worse we heard a
couple of dog barks I scattered some CS
powder around the path we took as we
move toward the new observation point
this would definitely slow the dog down
once it got CS powder up up its nose so
this is a nightmare like you you hear
these that's the way they signal to each
other is they have these bamboo things
that they're clacking together and you
know what it is it means there's
trackers how horrifying is that it gets
your attention when you hear it because
you know they're back there they have a
good idea of where we are and they've
got trackers who can follow you know a
trail and if you hear a dog bark um now
you know they've got dogs coming with
them um
so yeah that that kind of runs the
stress level up a little bit because you
know they're going to find you it's just
a matter of
time yeah you can't cover the tracks of
an seven-man Patrol I mean and the dog's
going to smell it even even if you you
cover it m the dog's going to smell it
CU you were there covering
[Music]
it fast forward a little bit it did not
take due for very very long to start
sending back information that we related
to cvy by 11:30 the first air strike
started hitting the air and this I'm
fast forward but you guys get into a
location you can now see what the NVA is
doing and you start dropping bombs on
them this increased the NVA effort to
find our location the clackers were
coming
closer fast forward soon we heard the
trackers Handler and a small group of
NVA go by us and continue up the ridge
that was close we decided to stay where
we were for our remain
overnight so
this is horrifying to me uh These Guys
these guys out there looking for us
tracking us that's just like a nightmare
like you said you know they're going to
find you it's just a matter of time
because they don't care they can move as
fast as they want they can pull out
machetes and hack their way through
there
and um fast forward to day three this
section's called We're
busted it was day three 25 December 1968
Christmas Day we moved from from our Ro
site back to the third and most distant
Cliff to set up our observation it had
rained during the night and the terrain
was slippery we had to be careful we
observed a lot of traffic just after we
got in position to reported to cvy in
less than 20 minutes we had f4s pounding
them we were able to provide targeting
data for about two hours before
everything appeared to have been
destroyed fast forward 2 minutes later
we heard a toe popper explode a loud
scream and almost simultaneously a
second toe popper explosion followed
immediately by a barrage of AK-47 fire
so this is because you would when you
guys would get in a your your static
positions you would set up your
Claymores which you talked about but
you'd also set up these little toe
popper landmines as indicators that
someone was coming and also an immediate
defensive scenario yeah so you you're
moving we use what we call the Fish
technique a lot you're moving along and
this is where you want your Ro in so we
moved past it go up turn and come back
to it so if you're tracking us You're
Gonna Go by us and when you get up the
Airways to to where we turn uh I'm going
to leave a little surprise for you so
put I you know I learned when I was a
little kid how people animals and things
Walk Through the Wood when they come to
this log M you just instinctly step over
or right on the other side of that log
where that toe far is going to be
and it just for fun I'd put two of them
over there so sometimes you'd step over
I'd take that leg off and you'd start to
fall you'd lend on the other one I get
that one too you step on one of those
out in the jungle you're going to die
because you can't get your back to the
hospital or anything like that but that
lets us know you know that you're
tracking us we know where you are and
most of the time when they would step on
one they assume we're out in front of
them and that's where they initially
fire they open fire out that way we're
back over here a little way so we know
you're there we got some idea of how
many people are there and you know from
there we've got our Claymores out on the
Avenues of approach that you might use
to come down uh to get us we've got an
evacuation plan on how we're going to go
um so then we take whatever action you
know seems to be right at that time well
we learned the uh fish hook method for
controlling and when we're going to set
up our perimeters we also learned when
you're when you get to a log they're
going to put a booby trap on the other
side like those lessons got passed down
direct uh so the they so they hit a toe
poper um and then another toe poer now
they start shooting machine gun fire and
I'm going to go back to the book some of
it was in our Direction some of it was
in other directions they didn't know
exactly where we were but in that first
barrage three AK rounds came through the
route on my left side and tore my shirt
as they went across my chest and through
the root on my right side you were
sitting in between these uh trees that
look like big rockets and like the fins
of the Rockets is what you're sitting
between I had just exhaled if I had just
inhaled the bullets would have taken the
top of my chest off when they came
across me they grazed just enough to
draw
blood it was obvious that the roots were
providing just concealment not cover I
had to get behind the tree I jumped
behind the tree with my Ruck which is 75
pounds in my left hand I heard another
toe popper go off followed by a loud
scream then the grenade I had left in
the area with the trip wire all the AK
fire shifted toward our position now
they were trying to flank us with a
group of about 20 NVA maneuvering around
to our right to push our backs against
the cliff the grenade I had put on my
side exploded and showed their flanking
Movement we had a full-fledged firefight
going on with more NVA coming down the
ridge deck gave me me the command to
detonate the first layer of Claymores it
was a tremendous explosion as seven
Claymores exploded simultaneously it was
raining debris dirt pieces of trees
rocks and body parts a bloody arm landed
right in front of where I had been lying
between the roots a thick smoke and
smell covered the jungle it temporarily
stopped their assault but the automatic
weapons fire picked up again it was easy
to tell that the group was a lot smaller
because of the lower volume of fire but
more NVA were coming as soon as the team
got near my position and below me I was
getting ready to set off the other layer
of Claymores when a b40 rocket hit the
tree in front of the one I was behind
fortunately my Ruck was still setting on
the edge of the bank and provided some
protection it was riddled with small
shrapnel I duck behind the tree and set
off the first the last layer of
Claymores this group had only five
Claymores but it ripped the hole in the
NVA assault they were stunned physically
and psychologically I don't think the
NVA believed we had more Claymores to
set off I also got another taste of the
impact of
adrenaline when I came out from behind
the tree I had to grab my ruck sack with
my left hand it weighed probably 75
pounds and I'm not a big guy but I toss
that ruck sack around like it was a
pillow I took it right I took it with me
as we fought our way down the Ridge and
toward the LZ I paid for it later on
after we got extracted I realized I had
pulled muscles in my shoulder because
they just weren't designed to handle
that much weight but I had so much
adrenaline pumping through my system I
didn't notice at the time Cowboy had
dropped off with me and was providing
OverWatch fire as I scampered down to
him deck and Jones were leading the team
down the ridge towards the LZ the rocky
terrain was providing some cover but the
NVA were able to take advantage of it
too as soon as the first toe popper
exploded I had notified cvy that we had
heavy contact and a prairie fire usually
cvy could assess could could have assets
on site in 30 to 45 minutes but it was
Christmas Day a holiday and not a lot of
assets were just hanging out nearby it
was a good thing that we had notified
cvy right away we needed close air
support gunships immediately we knew it
would be a while before things would
calm down enough to get extraction ship
in the NVA were not stopping cowboy and
I went into a delaying technique with
Claymores on time fuses that were
becoming pretty effective at using the
NVA appeared to have run right up on the
first delayed Claymore based on the
screams and yelling we heard Cowboy said
VC angry my response was good that means
we're really hurting them we left
another one as we ran up to catch up
with the rest of the team we were
shooting a lot of them but it seemed
like it was taking two to three hits to
put them down cowboy said VC take drugs
he must have been correct because they
were hard to stop I noticed that three
hits on automatic had a lot more
knockdown power than three fast
individual shots
when I hit them on auto they dropped
immediately I made a mental note to
remember this for later cvy told me that
he he had a couple of spads with 20 mm
and Napal 20 minutes out I updated our
situation we were still receiving a lot
of fire into our area as we caught up
with deck I updated deck on what cvy
said and about the problem putting NVA
down we had a steep grade to go down to
the LZ and got no protection once we got
there we decided to stay where we were
in the Rocks suddenly things got got
quiet too quiet they were up to
something we decided to put our four
claymor on the on the most likely
Avenues of attack we redistributed
ammunition and moved our extra frag and
Willy Peak grenades out of our rocks we
were expecting a heavy assault to begin
any minute you could hear a pin drop
then at a very low volume I heard Bravo
6 this is cvy six go spads a1s are here
Mark your position with smoke and tell
me where you want the 20 Mike mic I
threw a smoke grenade and said Roger
smoke out Sandy lead identifies yellow
six Roger make the first run north to
southeast northwest to Southeast 100
meters Northwest of the smoke danger
close Roger keep your heads
Down the Gun runs effectively triggered
the NVA assault on our position we
thought there were 20 to 30 of them left
it was closer to 200 one thing I had
learned is that if you you are not
moving you are dying because the NVA are
maneuvering into position to cut off
your escape the NVA had managed to move
so that they had flanked us on three
sides the only way we could Escape was
to run into the open LZ they were
assaulting we set off our four remaining
we set off four of our remaining seven
Claymores to slow their assault cvy this
is six have one spad put Napal where it
is first gun run and the second to drop
is Napal flying Northeast to South
Southwest 100 met north of the smoke
this is danger close do it now and come
back around with guns in the same place
cvy Roger you take you guys take cover
and take a deep breath it's going to get
very hot the gates of hell are about to
open six copy that meanwhile we are
being hit with a Hil of AK-47 and RPD
fire and b40 Rockets we returned the
fire and lob frag grenades from behind
rocks it was so Smoky you could barely
see when we heard the planes getting
close we each threw a grenade took cover
and took a deep breath the air was was
about to be so hot it would fry the
inside of your lungs the fireball heat
and smoke were tremendous and the Napalm
sucked all the oxygen out of the air air
was available but it was hot Smoky and
choking and had no oxygen we could see
the NVA running around like human
torches covered in Fire and screaming we
were still receiving a lot of fire from
the south cvy this is six that was
fantastic we are still receiving fire
from the south make one more Napal Rum
Run 100 meters south of the smoke flying
Northwest to South West danger close
this is cvy Roger we have four gunships
five mics out this is cvy Napal 30
seconds out take cover the Napal was
once again surreal the screams the
choking the superheated air the smoke
the smell of burning and charred flesh
we took out the human torches we could
see a couple of our guys could not take
the smell and could not hold back the
vomit once we had suppressed most of the
enemy fire we were able to bring in an
extraction ship as we were lifting off
still under Fire deck and I both threw a
red smoke grenade meaning the LZ was
cleared hot take out all living
creatures cvy worked the area over and
pulled away as we pulled away cvy this
is dynamite really appreciate your help
we could not have made it without you
thanks thank all of your assets for us
see you back at the ranch Roger that
Dynamite you guys did a great job today
as soon as we got far enough away from
the L
and most of the NVA fire shifted away
from us I looked over at deck to see his
big smile and thumbs
up he wasn't smiling and there was no
thumbs up I thought crap he must have
been hit I crawled across the guys to
get to him grabbed him by the shoulder
and asked deck you
okay he slowly looked up at me and said
Lieutenant I'm done this was my last
mission then he looked away I went back
to my position in the helicopter a lot
of questions popped into my mind I would
talk to him more about this we got to
the launch site when we got to the
launch site I immediately went to him
what's going on I asked he said I've
completed my mission requirement and I'm
going to move to a different job when we
get to C
CN I would appreciate if you wouldn't
say anything about it I'll tell the team
when the time is right we did a quick
debrief and flew back to what was left
of fob1 we got there after dark to find
the mess sergeant had saved our
Christmas meal for us steak if I
remember correctly it tasted really good
but the best part of was that fob1 even
almost totally closed did not forget
about us fuay was all right but this was
the end of fui fob1 it was being closed
as an fob and the teams distributed it
around the other fobs we would be the
last team out RT Idaho with John Striker
Meyer tilt and Lynn black Blackjack had
barely managed to escape from La that
day too and had already been transported
to CCN RT Alabama would rest that night
and fly to C Cen the following
morning
yeah this is insane right I mean the
this is these these stories are insane
they're totally insane um getting
pressed that hard blasting these
Claymores you know we used to set up
Claymore ambushes in training um and you
know when you clack off
seven seven Claymores in the jungle that
is a serious serious blast yeah that
must have rocked those NVA that rocked
their world I mean if rocked your world
yeah you have to make sure you're far
enough back or yeah because it'll stun
you
you know in in those
days um we didn't have a ter for and
talk about uh
TV you know I look at you and you days
and you can't tell me your name and I I
say ja rub a little dirt on your chest
just rub a little dirt on you'll be all
right you know let's keep going you know
we we got things to do we can't fumble
around like this just Rubble dirt on U
and you know we didn't we didn't realize
what the concussion was doing to us yeah
but I mean you're getting hit with it
you know on
know regular basis then you had Lynn
black he was getting ready to go on a
mission he goes out and trying to figure
out how big of a piece of C4 do we need
to use to knock somebody out well I'm G
to chop up these different sizes set of
out here on the ground back up a little
wa and set it off and see if it knocks
me down so he kept doing it until you
know he didn't know who he was and he
said okay that's that's how much we need
right there ohly C but anyway we used to
do Claymores also uh and I know they
don't do this anymore but I detonated
Claymores that were like on the other
side of my ruck sack and I was maybe in
a little depression like you can you can
be so close yeah to them I mean you get
rattled yeah but we used to do that just
to kind of explore the the the
parameters mhm because the you know the
bearings are going in the other
direction but you get a little Daz from
that we we tried whenever we could to
put them in front of trees so you got a
big tree and on the other side of the
Claymore and then you're you're back
here ways but you still got if you're
going to do seven at one time you still
got to get backway go holy cow um but
yeah when and one of the the things that
was happening was you know we were
closing
fob1
and most of the
teams and I I don't know all the answers
here but most of the teams left there
and went uh to uh CCN or or Central or
or
South as the intact team but for some
reason Alabama got split
up so when when we moved down there um
you know the team for a while wasn't a
team anymore so deck went to a different
type of job a non-operator job um down
there CCN was a it was a a big place a
lot going on did you talk to deck about
what yeah yeah I talked to him back and
he said what he saying I'm done he he
said you know I I finished my mission
requirements I been on all these things
they're going to split the team up uh
and they're going to move me to an admin
job they're going to take me to CCM but
you put me in a um a non-operator job
down there and I'm okay with that um and
and the team was split up and he told me
he had already given me the clearance to
be a one zero he had vetted me and I was
good um so I would get my my own team
when I got down
there yeah cuz I don't know if you
mentioned this on the podcast it's in
the book but the the what they wanted
out of you guys was six months or six
missions right that's what they wanted
out of you guys six months or six
missions so if you got to six months and
you were didn't want to do it anymore
you could move on or if you did six
missions you could move on or if the one
zero
said Joo can't do this got it he's going
get somebody killed maybe after your
first mission second mission if the one
to zero is said no thumbs down he's not
an operator take him out then you know
you could be moved somewhere else but
normally if you got six missions and you
want it but and the part of the the
thought was that that's a lot of
missions and if we keep you longer than
that then you know you might not not be
okay upstairs mhm you know we we need to
we're going to try to protect you by
getting you out after six or at least
giving you an out if you want it but in
reality you know it could be the first
mission that did you
in I mean there there are people who
went on one Mission and came back and
said that ain't happening again I can't
do this because it was so different when
you went across the
border you you just against so many
people every
time you you all and it it reminds me
jiujitsu I mean seems like every time I
see you guys on uh Instagram or
something you're doing some some
stuff one person gets down on the mat
and the other person gets on top and
gets some kind of hold on him or
something and then that's when you start
and that's kind of what sag was
like we're we're going to put the team
out there we're going to surround you
with all these NBA and then we're gonna
say
go because it you always started out
surrounded every Mission yeah it's like
we you know people talk about different
the different selection uh courses that
there are for for Rangers and for seals
and for special
forces I don't think there's a harder
selection than than so you're going to
go out on a mission over the fence and
we'll see if we if you hack it or not
let see if we can find you again
yeah I mean it's it's not funny but it's
amazing how many teams went
out you they got off the helicopter they
moved into the jungle and that was it
you didn't hear from them
again or maybe you find one or two of
them at some point
but you had some uh Lessons Learned From
This one uh if you can be heard you can
be found if you can be found you can be
killed uh if you're not moving you are
losing the battle you are in the process
of
dying yeah when you
stop and and you get distracted you get
sucked in by here's a group of rocks
they're coming after here's a group of
rocks you know rocks are conceal are not
just concealment but cover so we get
down in these rocks you know now we can
stand there ground and we can get some h
no all that does is is fixate you in one
little spot in NVA it's just like a big
amoeba coming down and and they just go
around you now you're not going anywhere
I used to have the young seals out in
the field doing land Warfare and they
being a enemy contact so this you know
it's like lasers are getting shot at and
all of a sudden you know the the lasers
would kind of slow down then they'd come
to a stop and you'd see the young leader
be like oh you know they're not shooting
at us anymore forer perimeter and you
know start doing counts and ammo
redistribution and I'd say hey man
what's going on you'd be like well they
stop shooting at us that's cuz they're
maneuvering like that they're moving on
you right now and now you don't know you
knew where they were at least when they
were shooting at you now you don't know
so you need to now's not the time to
stop now's not the time to get
stationary now's not the time to get
static unless you have some prominent
High ground or something like that a
piece terrain feature okay but if you're
still if you're if you'd maneuvered down
a Ravine and now you're in some low
ground and you think it's going to be a
good time to stop and redistribute ammo
no now's not the
time so I definitely related to that one
uh Claymores on time fuses stun the
assaulting NVA made the survivors stop
and think they are human they don't want
to get
shredded and uh Napal was a very scary
and powerful weapon the NVA hated
it yeah so that and that was that was a
big insight for me using
Napal and just seeing you know the
awesome power of that stuff and and what
it did
and
realizing they don't want it I mean if
you get in real trouble you bring some
Napal out there and you know they'll
change how they react to you because
once you see your buddy as a human torch
or people just charred all over the
place you don't want any of it and it
you know I've had it on me you you it
won't go out you you know and it doesn't
just rub off it just sets on your other
hand on fire when you start trying to
put it out I mean it it's going to get
you um and it's it's just really really
brutal the other thing that you run into
or we ran into I ran into um was I work
mostly North and as you went north um
the jungle got a lot thicker so all of a
sudden you had double and triple canopy
jungle when you see all of these YouTube
videos and things of napon being dropped
it's out in the open MH and man it it
forms this beautiful pattern on the
ground and everything and that's cool
when you drop it into a double canopy
jungle or Triple Canopy it goes off up
there and it goes everywhere it starts
raining down and it used to just scare
me but I knew I had to have it but I
said you know I hope I'm picking the
right distance I hope that pilot that's
coming in is going to put it in the
right spot and I hope I didn't make a
mistake or he didn't make a mistake in
our calculations or it's going to be on
us and you just kind of hold your breath
and say oh jeez we see what happens you
know when it comes
down but the nv8 what they started
trying to do in ' 69 was try to get get
close get close tried to get close
enough to us that we couldn't call it in
so you couldn't wait too late before you
you used
it but it was a powerful weapon
mhm
um I'm going to fast forward here to
command and control North
fob4 and now you're with uh RT Michigan
RT Michigan had a reputation as a solid
team and it lost its last two one
zeros unlike RT Alabama RT Michigan was
a monard team so there always got to be
a little bit um dis discomforting when
you're going to take a job that the last
two guys have been killed well it it
almost didn't matter which team you went
to probably the reason you were going to
that team is CA it one zero yeah I mean
if when you made
contact if you could survive the first
90 seconds you might have a
chance it was just amazing how many one
Zer and Americans were killed in the
first 90 seconds because everybody you
all stand you're standing
up so I mean your whole body now is
exposed and when that many people open
up with that many AKs on automatic
there's such a barrage coming at you if
you're standing up you're going to get
hit if you can get below waste level you
know by the time the shooting starts
you've got a chance I mean that one
reason I didn't want any more than I had
to on the front I wanted to the degree I
could to look like an empty pair of
fatigues laying out there on the ground
that I was so close to the ground you
know that I I wasn't going to get my
ruck sack used to get shot all the
pieces you know cuz it was it was
sticking
up but you know uh my ruck sack saved me
on a lot of occasion or radio saved me I
got hit so many times in that
radio but you got to get close you got
to get down you and I I still harass
tilt you know and and I think tilt said
on the the podcast the first thing his
team said to him when he went to his new
team The Interpreter said you got going
to die too tall yeah yeah it wasn't just
too tall you're too tall and you're too
ugly you're going to
die and I you know I I harassed myself
how can you know I used to look at you
and say how can a guy
62 survive out
here I mean yeah I can I can just site
time after time where if I had been a
quarter of an inch caller I'd have died
you know and I'm nowhere near
60 um so I don't know I mean I've had my
head creased with a chunk of shrapnel
and stuff like that it just you know I
used to want to be taught you know CU my
little brother's 6'4 how old are you um
5'7 mhm so 5'8 you wouldn't be here no I
wouldn't be here no not at
all uh so Michigan you say in my
experience with so this is a mountain
yard a mountain yard team and you say in
my experience with them the yards did
not like the Vietnamese I would need to
adap from the Vietnamese culture and
superstitions to that the of the
mountain yards so you got a different
crew now and you got to get used to
these guys what what was different about
the mountain
yards most of them had lived in the
jungle and they came from the jungle so
they had a a lot of experience and
knowledge about the jungle uh the
creatures the terrain everything out
there so you know when when they move
through the
jungle they could they'd point out a lot
of times snake you know they knew where
to look to find the snakes where they
were going to be things like that um
just they were really good at moving
through the woods or the jungle and and
not making noise um different just a
different mindset than the Vietnamese
what kind of superstitions did they have
don't step over one of them
somebody if you were to step over me I
was going to die okay so you know don't
step over them they they get
hostile you start to do that and then
like it says in the book I mean that
that first day bargewell and and I and
one of the the yards are walking across
the the company area you know we kind of
three a breast when we walking along
and in the yard just reaches over and he
takes me by the hand mhm he's holding my
hand and we're kind of walking along and
we swinging our hands and you know I'm
looking down and thinking what what are
we doing here we don't do this in South
Carolina yeah we don't do this in South
Carolina and and bargewell looks and he
says don't turn it
loose he said it's not what you think
he's showing you respect and honor if
you turn his hand loose you're going to
insult him mhm and you don't want to do
that but you know just different things
it was different culture um the food was
a little different that they ate uh they
really didn't like the Vietnamese they
didn't care if they were North or South
they didn't care they just you know yeah
I mean they killed each other some
sometimes in the compounds oh yeah in
the compound yeah I mean you couldn't
let them eat at the same time we had uh
you know cambodians and and the mountain
yards and and the Vietnamese they all
ate in the same Messa but they had to
have a different feeding schedule you
couldn't put them in there together
because somebody would get shot because
it was it was like living in the old
west unlike the US compounds in the saw
compounds you know you walked around
fully arm I mean you could carry
grenades around your pocket you could
carry your car 15 around in the compound
with you know fully loaded ready to go
uh and you subject to get shot and one
one thing you didn't want to do I mean I
didn't want to walk up you know to eeko
and say something that appeared to be
aggressive or derogatory to him when his
team was with him I mean I'd be looking
down the barrels car 15s all of a sudden
and nobody's going to mess with the you
know with the with the one zero on the
team
and you know so you you had to be care
even Americans you know we all carried
weapons too so you had to be careful
with them some of them are
whacko uh you mentioned barwell uh you
say this about barwell I was impressed
with barsell right from the beginning he
was very knowledgeable and a great
operator he had been at Kon with a team
during the siege of Kon they were
hammered for 77 Days by a massive NVA
Force barsell had recruited some of the
RT Michigan team members
this was a yard team and they all liked
him and had a lot of respect for him he
was a smart guy everything about him
said Warrior I figured if he didn't get
killed he was going to be a legend in
Special Ops at some point sure enough
barsell remained in Special Operations
SOG Rangers Delta and Socom throughout
his career and retired as a major
general and special ops
Legend we remained friends until his
death April 29th 2019
and yeah I mean uh barell was in charge
of sock year Special Operations Command
Europe um when I was over there and you
know it was pretty awesome my boss had a
really good relationship with him and
you know it was pretty pretty awesome to
be working with a legend like that but
that's when he was a general you were
working with him when he was what a spec
four yeah he's a hard
dude you know but even I mean there's
not a another
General Who as a general instead of
walking around with his little pistol
walked around with an AK-47 slung over
his
shoulder and and telling you know his
security team if anything happens guys
you take care of yourself I'll take care
of me I'll be all right you know don't
get yourself kill trying to take care of
me yeah and holy cow but I mean he was
uh he was hard just a
unbelievable Warrior um smart and you
know he was a spec four and we come back
to the States and and I see him and uh
he was a a lieutenant and I thought how
did you do that well you know I came
back and went to OCS okay then I see him
again he's a
captain and I'm you know I'm just the a
major and he's already a
captain I thought man you're doing good
and then the next time I see him uh you
know he was a major and I was about to
get promoted to Lieutenant caral I mean
he'd already caught me and just you know
he just kept going and you know that was
cool and you know I'd see him in
different places and we'd talk and you
know when he was in Delta we were
talking and and stuff and it was um yeah
it was pretty cool just to watch him he
was fascinating but on these teams m i
mean he was he was a hard dude you
didn't want to irritate him I mean and I
think I think that's part of what how he
got a
DSC
was his team after I left the team was
hit a b40 came right into the middle of
them everybody was wounded barwell took
a big piece of shrapnel through the
through the side of his face and ldes
behind the eye on the other side and it
it really irritated him and then they
they they had the G about 20 of them to
stand up and try to assault the team you
know and they're wounded and all this
stuff and Bar's got a B piece of straing
on his head and he's pissed and he's he
was and he had that he had he was
carrying the the RPD by then he holds
the whole group down I mean he just took
out their whole assault by himself and
he modified an RPD right like yeah we
cut down there's a mission
where he got so
excited I mean the bad guys are using it
against us and he just kept talking
about man that thing's awesome it fires
so fast it's got that big 100 round belt
on it and he does all this stuff and he
kept talking and then so I said well
we're going over on a training Mission
over to the monkey mountain
Carri one over there and just see what
you think about it you know going
through the
jungle when he came back and said no you
know it hangs on everything it's heavy
it's you know that bipod hangs on all
this stuff then the next thing I know he
tells me this guy's down at
CCC saw the barrel off of one of these
things and he did some modifications to
it it's a lot shorter I and he got one
of them
and he started carrying it yeah yeah the
seals were you know they used
m60sbs
one time holy
cow I got back I will never do that
again hangs on everything it's heavy
and when the bad guys hear that machine
it sounds so different just like an RPD
it sounds so different than everything
else they know what it is and everybody
just you know all the the rounds start
coming at that weapon but they know
they've got to take it out yeah you
didn't like that done too much
no uh so now you're you're with this
team and you're you know practice
practice practice this is your montra
now you're practicing everything where
to put a tourniquet on uh you get you
start enforcing the meals things and you
know this was a detail I wanted to bring
up just CU it's it's an example of what
you guys were how focused you were the
snaps on a canteen the canteen cover the
little snaps you replace those with
wooden buttons so if you're getting a
drink no one's going to hear snapping
any snaps that's that's where you guys
were at you're practicing with the
Claymores um this is where you get into
the point where you had an eight man
teen you got approximately 24 Claymores
you were a big fan the Claymores and the
grenade same thing you know uh eight-man
Team you got guys carrying 10 frag
grenades which is pretty
epic well you know and I told them I
said the good thing one of the good
things about carrying all that
ammunition is the bad the bad news is
it's heavy the good news is that when we
make contact it gets lighter and lighter
you know but then it turns into the bad
news after a while because it's gone but
but yeah so I tried to pump them up a
little bit about the stuff but they saw
I mean it they were they were shocked
when they they realized the power that
we had with those Claymores and all
those frag grenades particularly when
you made contact at night MH because at
night you can lob that grenade out there
and they don't know where it came from I
can't imagine the horror of your walking
and you think you're assaulting this
little so and as your on assault all a
sudden seven Claymores get clacked off
half your guys are dead or wounded so
you go well that must be all they have
you charge again and you hit four like
that's that's
devastating uh fast forward a little bit
here to your first mission you say my
first mission as one Zer so now you're
the guy in charge of RT Michigan was to
provide assistance to a hatchet Force
platoon LED by my friend Captain Glenn
Jordan that would be interdicting a
resupply route and this is a pretty cool
Mission because that's actually is
similar to what uh my guys would do over
in ratti which is you dressed up like
members of the
101st and went down to with them made it
look like you were replacements for some
of their soldiers and then when their
water supply team went down to the river
to resupply their water you guys took
off your 101st uniforms got on your your
put our bman suit on put on your so your
SOG outfits and then boom rolled out
that's you know my guys would do stuff
like that roll out with the Army you
know in their convoys and they'd pull up
they'd stop for whatever reason out guys
would slip out the back and go start
occupying buildings or foot patrol in or
whatever any we did a bunch of different
that type of thing
um
so going fast forward a little bit
you're on this mission now and someone
has your day three of this Mission
someone has a genius idea at 1410 we
heard bad news from cvy x-ray 5 this is
cvy the launch site is sending a
helicopter to resupply your water food
and batteries your mission has been
extended the chopper is 10 minutes out
you'll need to identify your location
over this is x-ray 5 not going to happen
I say again no way we have bad guys all
over us we cannot Mark our location to
receive supplies send it
away this is cvy I sent your response to
Quebec Tango 6 he said it's coming get
ready to receive it sorry about that
this is five I'm not marking my location
this is Cubby the Chopper's been ordered
to drop the supplies at your last known
location this is five you know this is
going to create a prairie fire you
better start lining up assets this is
going to be they're going to be on us
like chicken on a June
bug I got barsell Nash and canu
together and told him what was about to
happen it was not a pleasant
conversation probably too loud in the
end I told him we would not
stop in the end I told them we could not
stop our position from being compromised
and we needed to at least try and hide
the supplies from the NVA so they would
not find them when they came looking for
us we would not have much
time so of course this happens I
mean this is just a nightmare freaking
tell these idiots not to send these
resupplies they send them you're hidden
you're you're totally clandestine at
this point they drop supplies fast
forward enemy contact Cy this is five
moving south fast we can hear them
coming we need air support here now
calling artillery and this is something
you went into you had laid out an
awesome pre-fired plan all the locations
you named all the locations all the
pre-fire locations and dialed those in
with 100 because this was your first
time when you're going to be close
enough to yeah American forces to
actually use artillery so you were
pumped yeah
um cubby this is five moving south fast
we can hear them coming in we need air
support here now calling
artillery cvy Roger gunships 20 mics out
working on spads are you calling a
prairie fire this is five
soon x-ray 26 x-ray 5 fire mission over
so here you are calling in uh the the
artillery um Eagle 26 shot over Eagle 26
splashed over this is five outstanding
more to come
we were moving fast toward an area that
we could use for an extraction LZ
suddenly CA signaled halt enemy just as
we stopped a barrage of AK fire came at
us hitting ca he went down in the
vegetation cantua yelled CA hit I yelled
assault front we needed to get online an
assault Beyond where Campell went down
so we could get him as we got near CA we
found RPGs were coming at us we had to
get CA and start moving backwards there
at least 20 more NVA as we were fighting
and trying to withdraw I worked my way
over to ca he was bleed bleeding badly
barsell was trying to stop the bleeding
barsell personally recruited Campo when
he was at Kon he knew ca's family cvy
this is five we're in heavy contact with
20 more MVA need help we have at least
one redhead code word for wounded I'm
declaring Prairie Fire emergency
over I shouted over the background heavy
volume of gunfire and yelling Roger that
can you send up a flare we don't know
exactly where you are Roger stand by
this is five flare up identify this is
cvy identify blue this is five negative
negative that's not us hammer it sending
up another one this is cvy identify red
Roger that standing by artillery coming
in eal 26 x-ray 5 fire mission over
Roger send it from Target Friday
Direction 270 add 250 adjust fire over
Eagle 26 Roger shot over so this is you
know for people that don't know uh
what's going on here this Mark Mark you
identify thing is something that you do
when you're trying to mark your position
so you try and Mark your position for
the aircraft that are
overhead and you throw out a you know
what you throw out you threw out a
smoke or a flare flare a flare and you
say identify and they are supposed to
say what color flare you sent up so they
say yep you sent up a blue flare well
you didn't send up a blue flare so
you're saying hey wherever that flare
came from they're not friendly so hammer
that
thing but that's how good the enemy was
like they would know if they would send
up just random signaling devices they
might be able to get confusion going
on uh fast forward a little bit the NVA
had cut off our route to the possible LZ
and their numbers were increasing we
made it into some rocks they were trying
to flow around us barsell had cambas
bleeding under control and gave him
ringer solution to get some of the
volume back in his blood cvy this is
five this is as far as we can go run the
guns again same place we need a string
extraction if you can get here fast
enough these jokers look like a giant
amoeba flowing around their dinner I
want to give them indigestion really I
really appreciate Quebec Tango's
resupply of food he should be with us
here to enjoy it
over I knew
listen yeah I was sure I was sure Quebec
Tango 6 could hear what I was saying
even with the heavy volume of gunfire
explosions and Men yelling in the
background cvy Roger guns coming back
around working on strings spads here in
five mics Roger getting ready this is
thick canopy not sure they can get the
things the strings through Roger I'll
notify Casper 5 extraction on strings
through double canopy jungle was rough
we would be dragged through the limbs of
trees and Treetops the aircraft would
always start to go forward before we
were above the canopy and then we would
be being dragged through it this is
Casper 5 we are doing we are here to do
some fishing ready to put four lines in
the water the Maguire rigs have been
removed watch for
sandbags x-ray 5 Roger move 12:00 40
MERS and 3:00 20 MERS so this is just
chaos going on um we are over your fish
bed you're over our fish bed drop the
lines we were receiving heavy fire and
the extraction aircraft did not want to
stay over us long the strings would be
120t nylon ropes with a a sandbag on the
end of each to get them through the
canopy if they left the Maguire rigs on
the ropes they would hang up in the
canopy this meant we had to use our
nylon utility ropes measuring 12 feet to
make Swiss seats while laying down and
getting shot at and then hook onto the
ropes while we were lying on the
ground while this was going on four
people would not be returning the NVA
fire at the NVA barw Well's first group
to be extracted were tossing some of
their loaded magazines in a pile for my
group to use we were quickly running out
of survival time The Hourglass had only
had almost run out of sound of sand I
really didn't think there was much of a
chance that my group would get out so
you're freaking
surrounded you got eight guys on the
ground that need to get out you they're
going to be dropping sandbags on the end
of ropes from a helicopter through the
double canopy jungle that are going to
hopefully Land close enough to you guys
where while you're freaking laying down
you can put a piece of rope around your
waist in a Swiss seat and then Carabiner
yourselves into these ropes that's the
plan and you're going to have to do that
twice by the way and you're running out
of
ammunition
yeah it was a it was a stressful
day oh yeah that's right you got wounded
as
well
uh here we go I put barsell Nash can AA
and aat on the first aircraft strings I
wanted the two Americans CA and aat out
I couldn't help the group get hooked up
because the NVA were starting to charge
our
position I was shooting some of them
within 10 feet or less of our perimeter
and some even inside our
perimeter my magazine ran out just
before one of them jumped over my rock
and landed on me I terminated him with
my Kar to his neck hitting his koted
artery as he landed on me we were
receiving a heavy volume of fire the NVA
realized what we were trying to do and
were really trying hard to kill us and
shoot our helicopter down it wasn't
every day they got a chance to shoot
down a helicopter 100 feet in the air
and not moving we had to be careful not
to use our grenades up too quickly we
are going to be fighting for a while
Casper 5 you have our fish go go
straight up fast have your door Gunners
flood the Willie Pete you are about to
see I shouted over the gun fire
explosions and yelling Roger I threw a
white phosphorus grenade as far as I
could toward the main body of the
NVA Willie Pete grenades were big and
heavy and had a large bursting radius I
had to get it far enough away before it
exploded which was not easy while
receiving a heavy volume of fire and
idiots diving on
me the wiie Pete grenade created a dense
white smoke with small chunks of wiie
Pete landing on and burning through the
NVA the dense white smoke provided some
concealment for barsell group and acted
as a choke Ching Point as a choking
agent in the nv's
lungs Casper 5 this is x-ray five take
him straight up over this is Casper 5
we're taking hits we have to get out of
here this is x-ray 5 have your door
Gunners move their their fire 25 meters
north of where they currently firing
over Casper Roger the door Gunners
returned continued to return fire I
could see the red tracers coming down to
the ground and I was on the radio trying
to adjust the door Gunner's fire because
I could see where the NVA were on the
ground I was trying to get katuna and
hang or hang how do I say his name hang
ready to hook on the next set of ropes
if there was a next set I returned fire
at the NVA as I talked to cvy to tell
him where I needed the gunships to make
their gun runs while I was dodging
bullets I saw that CA Nash akat and
barwell were getting beat up through the
tree limbs I couldn't help them now they
would have to survive the ride to
Firebase two the fun things that SOG one
zero got to do were be the first person
off the aircraft Into the Fire fight and
the last one off the ground during
extraction but that's what SOG one zeros
did first in last
out I had only a couple frag grenades
left and the NVA were getting ready to
assault again I got out my two-b blocks
of C4 and inserted the blasting caps
that had been crimped on the time fuses
with fuse igniters I had only one
Claymore left I set up the Claymore
facing the direction of the most NVA
unrolled the wire and put the clacker
under the Rope on my hip so it would be
fastened to me and I could reach it to
detonate the Claymore my plan was to set
it off just before I got to the end of
The Wire 100 ft as I was lifted
up the gunships were keeping most of the
NVA back from us but a few were moving
closer to us they wanted to literally
hit us and maybe the helicopter as we
were being lifted up I had always told
my guys if you were not moving you dying
and here we were we couldn't move
because we had to wait to be lifted up
on strings through the canopy our death
sentence seemed to be rapidly
approaching we had only three courses of
action at this point one try to survive
getting lifted out on strings if the
pilot was willing to try and receive so
much fire two try to break contact and
disappear into the jungle and hope to be
found alive in a few days or three make
a stand here until we ran out of ammo
then throw a red smoke grenade
indicating that the gunships and A1
skyraiders were cleared hot to totally
destroy our current location and take
out as many NVA as they could I didn't
like the third
option I decided to have the gunships
make two more passes but much closer to
our position and have the extraction
chip follow right behind them we would
fasten the ropes as fast as possible and
give us clearance to lift out I would
provide covering fire while assisting
katun and hang and hooking up if I had
time and was able I would fasten on if I
couldn't for some reason wounded dead or
too much fire I would send katuna and
hang out and stay behind and Implement
course of action two or
three
so that's what your decision is you're
going to try and at least get these
other two guys out of here if you get
the chance you're going to hook onto
that
rope and if you can't you're just going
to send them off and you're just going
to go down fighting and call in fire on
your own
position x-ray 5 Casper 4 we are
dropping ropes now Roger one is hung up
on the canopy fortunately we only needed
three katun and hang hooked onto their
ropes while lying on the ground behind
the Rocks the gun runs were just about
on top of us and they took out a few of
the guys who crept in on us I didn't
have to help katuna and and and hang
very much so I just provided cover fire
Casper 4 x-ray take us up now straight
up we were taking a lot of fire I felt
two really hard hits in the back one in
the radio and one in the upper left
chest and knocked the breath out of me
it literally hurt it really hurt but I
did not think the bullets penetrated me
I was still alive and that was good as I
neared the end of the Claymore cord I
detonated it I was almost directly above
it it was very loud and actually took
out some of the NVA and stunned me a
little so that's just freaking
ridiculous let me explain that to people
so you you're all this is going on
and as all this is going on you rig
up a claymore pointed in the direction
of the where the biggest concentration
of of NVA was and then you detonate the
the Claymore with something called a
clacker it's just a little it's a big
button actually that you squeeze and it
sends the P El electric shock wave down
this wire which is 100 feet long and
then when it gets there detonates the
electric blasting cap and blows up so
what you did was take that clacker stuck
in in your rope and then as you're being
hoisted up out of this hole in through
the canopy when you got to the end of
that wire you clacked off the Claymore
that's some serious freaking presence of
M
um you say I was having difficulty
shooting accur accurately or even in the
right place because I was being twisted
and turning and hitting limbs I dropped
two blocks of C4 with 15sec time fuse
they made a lot of noise now the NVA
were behind me and it was difficult to
shoot in that direction I could tell
both katuna and hang were hit because
blood was dripping down on
me I had no idea how bad they were
wounded both seemed to be alive I tried
to Radio Casper and cvy but the prick 25
radio which had been hit by two AK-47
rounds would not work I tried to use my
URC 10 survival radio but it had it had
been hit with a large piece of shrapnel
and was not working it was covering my
heart I was very fortunate that it
stopped the shrapnel at least that part
worked but this left me with no way to
communicate with the helicopter or
cvy it was a long ride back to the first
safe place to land the helicopter and to
add to the fun we flew over several
anti-aircraft positions but it felt good
to be off the
ground and there's actually a photograph
in the book which is freaking ridiculous
and you tell the story about how you got
this but it's a picture of you and uh
who's it hang and and um canant and
Canton and you guys are getting lowered
into a different fire base after you've
been in this gunfight look at this Echo
Charles look at this
yeah that's so a guy happened to snap
the picture on an old type of Polaroid
camera I didn't know they had Polaroid
cameras in 1969 but this guy had one and
he snapped a picture of you guys as you
were getting dragged back into this fire
base and then before you took off once
you loaded back in the helicopter he ran
over to you and gave it to you yeah he
saw you know he saw bargewell group come
in I mean everybody there was just they
were in shock I mean you don't see they
didn't see people hanging under
helicopters on
ropes and they never saw anybody coming
from that direction on the other side of
the border so this was a this was a big
deal so this guy ran back and got his
little camera he came back out you know
cuz he they could tell another
helicopter was coming so as I came in he
he took the picture of us as they were
luring us down and you know takes about
60 seconds for it to process and
everything and they uh put me in the
helicopter and the other two in the
helicopter and we were just starting to
lift off and he came running with his
hand stuck out and I what is he doing
and and you know he got there just in
time and I took what he had in his hand
out and I looked at it and I said holy
cow this is a
picture and I have no clue who this guy
was or anything but you know he gave me
an actual photo of Us coming in and in
in the book book it talks
about the ropes were not excuse me even
and it ended up the rope that I had was
about 10 feet
longer than what the other two had and
then in the picture you can see it I'm
hanging down below them yeah and I mean
it was a it was total chaos and you
know they were lifting up and then it
pulled me off balance and I fell and
bounc and went into you know the the
thicket and all that stuff and Drug up
through it and and then you know I'm
hanging at we're at 7,000 ft above
ground level freezing yeah you know 100
miles an hour all the stuff soaking wet
from the sweat and heat that you just
left and oscillating back and forth and
I'm looking up and I can see my rope
rubbing on the edge of the helicopter
floor and it's starting to freay
you know I'm I'm at 7 7,000 ft so I'm
thinking
um that's a 30 second delay or a little
more before I hit the ground I mean if
I'm going to go down I mean you know I
can do some back Loop some turns and you
know little things before I Splat holy
cow you know just trying to distract
myself a little bit so yeah it would be
it would be interesting to try and
recreate that
scene somehow like in in a computer
Graphics or like a movie or something
cuz it would look totally insane like
you can't TR what you did what your guys
did is
not it's I mean the fact that you're
alive is is crazy uh I mean the
helicopters up there how that thing's
not getting shot down I have no idea um
I mean it only takes one bullet to knock
down a helicopter if it hits the right
spot yeah the one thing that that helps
the helicopter is if you were under
double or triple canopy jungle I mean
they were not standing you know right
under it shooting up at it they're
shooting at an angle so they're going
through the trees and the tree limbs and
you know canopies and and they can't see
it unless they're really close to it cuz
it you know we didn't blow a hole or
anything they just Dro it right down
through the
vegetation so they can hear it up there
they just can't see it and you know one
one thing that trees do is they deflect
and some cases stop
bullets and i' I've had conversations
with gunship pilots and stuff and and
one guy Berry pincheck has got a book
out and I did a little video and it was
it was a video kind of like
um Let me let me share with you uh you
know from his his part I'll I'll tell
you what it looked like to me when I was
placing all fire support down there for
you and I get to say well let me tell
you what it looked like when it came
through or what came through most of the
stuff you were shooting down it it never
hit the ground you know because it's
hitting trees and rck cing it's all
kinds of things it's a very different
perspective from the air versus you know
being on the ground um so that I mean
that was fun just kind of going back and
forth about you know what it looked like
the other thing that's crazy to try and
imagine is how they could find you in
all that I mean sure you throw out smoke
but the Smoke Gets dissipated through
the can yeah when you're under a canopy
like that you got to use the flares they
can see you might have to shoot two or
three but eventually want to penetrate
the canopy and come out and they'll see
it you know so here's this Bri bright
blue you know flare up there and for
them them to come over and be able to
get on that spot yeah well I'm me I'm
giving them a little guidance I mean
they they got talking on a bit yeah so
I'm I'm guiding right left
whatever and meanwhile you're rigging up
Claymore rigging up 15sec time fuse on
C4 blocks hooking up your Swiss
seat Sho enemy yeah the Swiss seat was
that was a pain to because you had to
lay down had to lie on the ground keep
them getting shot try to put that you
got a ruck sack on you got all this
stuff on and you're trying to fit that
thing around you and people are shooting
at you and and the longer you don't
shoot back you know the more they're
assaulting and coming out you and when
it got down to just a three of us you
know you didn't have a lot of Firepower
to start
with and then I I knew what I knew what
Cana and and H were thinking
because they had asked me one
day and I'm not sure whose idea it was
to ask if it was The Interpreter K was
hang m79 guy and Kenta says
it says H wants to
know why we have to always come out last
with
you and I said well because that I need
you guys you're important You're The
Interpreter you and I can talk he's the
m79 guy we need the Firepower and that's
just the way we're going to do it you
two come out last with me every time MH
because we're a team and and we can work
together they didn't like I was going to
say they love that didn't
they uh fast forward a little bit here
so you get out of this is a miracle that
you guys get out of here um you say uh I
was not happy about the resupply captain
Welch the Recon company Commander had
flown to the launch site to be part of
getting RT Michigan out to talk to me
before I talked to Major Sims and to
attend the debriefing to make sure
things me did not get out of hand
he told me before he went inside to take
to stay calm remember I would be talking
to a major and not to hit or shoot
anyone and I had to make sure that the
team did not do that either so that's
your pre-brief for the debrief hey don't
hit or shoot
anybody I was not
happy not happy at all did he have any
reason at all like what was his freaking
thinking they they needed us to stay
longer and that was fine MH we could
have stayed longer and they were
determined they were doing us a favor if
they gave us more you know water and
batteries and stuff like that we could
stay there because we were we were
across the
highway and providing protection and
support for the the hatchet force that
was down there so we were kind of
covering this whole area over here and
the NBA were coming down from up above
and they would stop and fire mortars
over the platoon well we could hear them
and you know I would call the artillery
because I had marked targets all around
there and tell them you know where to
where to shoot and we were close enough
to them I mean we'd hear them every time
they drop around yeah so uh they needed
us over there to keep the bad guys away
from them
but we could have done it
differently and at a different time that
was not that was not a good time to do
that so lucky to get out of there for
sure
definitely learned a lot a lot of things
we going to do different the next time
um I was just going to say that one of
the things that that happens
is all of this stuff starts to
collapse down into SOG
imperatives that when we get into book
two it kind of comes together and here
it is do these things you know if you
want to go out on the so Mission and and
have a successful Mission here's some
things you need to do but you know if
you want to run a
company if you want to run your life if
you want to do
things these
apply every day when you get up you
think you know what you're going to do
that
day but you know there are people out
there who didn't set in on the planning
session and they're going to mess you up
and you've got to be able to adapt adapt
adapt as you go along you got to
practice you got to do these things that
we're talking about here to be
successful in everyday life or in your
business or military or whatever it is
that you're going to do yeah so all of
this stuff kind of yeah you know I as I
was saying oh you were lucky to get out
of there it's a miracle you got out of
there which look you already gave
luck it's fair share right we all
understand that luck matters at the same
time you guys planned you guys prepared
you guys rehearsed you knew like how to
put that Swiss seat on you knew how to
do it in the dark you know how to do it
in the light you know how to do it late
like you practiced those things you knew
how to rig that Claymore you knew how
how to get those 15-second time fuse you
know where that where that C4 was on
your gear you could do it with your eyes
closed with your eyes open with the
bloody hands with whatever you and your
team knew that and so even though look
we say Miracle we say luck which
certainly you're going to have some but
if you didn't have the rehearsals the
practice the mindset the attention to
detail the
planning you wouldn't have been able to
do anything uh you you would have died
15 minutes into this operation so yes we
give luck and miracles they're due for
sure but the planning the fact that you
had all those pre pre uh scheduled fire
positions from for the artillery you
were able to just call them up
immediately the interaction that you had
with uh with the aircraft overhead like
everything that was going on was because
you had planned and prepared for it
so you practice what you preach and in
the book you preach practice practice
practice and that's exactly what you did
and that's how you were able to survive
this situation
which
is practically
unsurvivable I mean it's practically
unsurvivable if you would if you
wouldn't be sitting here talking to me
right now I wouldn't think that anyone
would survive that how can you survive
that practice preparation skill honing
getting better every time you do it like
that's what you guys did and that's what
kept you
alive um I'm going to fast forward a
little bit
here uh mission two with with rt
Michigan and this is a you guys are out
looking for a prisoner prisoner
snatch which yeah this is going to be a
good
one this is our specialty yeah you my my
spe not the teams you know I can't put
it on them I just there are things that
happen so
uh our new mission was to conduct a
prisoner snatch from area Oscar 8 we had
an insertion date of 12 January 1969
that would not give us much time to
prepare and again in the book get the
book you get to read all these all these
uh preparation that you do you get to
see the training that you're doing the
specialized training that you're doing
you can hear about the um the visual
reconnaissance I'll tell you a little
bit about it so the visual
reconnaissance once again this is when
you're flying over the the area of
operations to get a look at it barwell
and I left out of daang Airfield at
daylight in an Air Force O2 skymaster
observation aircraft to fly a visual
reconnaissance of the Oscar 8 area of
operations we plan to make one pass over
the target area taking photos as we flew
over and route to a fake area that we
would pretend to check out it was a
somewhat cloudy day and the air was very
rough as we approached the AO the NVA
welcomed us with fire from a couple 51
caliber machine guns around hit the
right wing flap and another came through
the floor hitting the pilot in the leg
the pilot was bleeding badly in a great
deal of pain and struggling to control
the plane we were all over the sky which
actually made us more difficult to hit
meanwhile the rounds were still coming
up at us another round came through the
cargo compartment just behind barsell
and out through the top of the plane
causing the rear engine to shut down I
said to barsell I I think I've seen
enough for
today he
agreed so you had to go and tour get the
Pilot's leg I mean this is freaking
chaos just on the
VR I yeah I hated those things you
didn't like going on the visual
reconnaissance no I I I knew it could
provide me a lot of intelligence but it
just seemed like every time I went out
there something like this
happened and I just think oh
jeez what are they going to do today to
screw my plan up are we going to shoot
the pilot that's
great and Oscar eight was a bad bad
right oh yeah bad place reputation as a
really bad
a uh in now in the book you start
talking
about now you got the visual
reconnaissance done you start planning
you start the preparation and that the
idea is and it's what you talked about
earlier with being able to disable
someone an enemy in an ambush
and basically you make a hole in the
Kill Zone of an ambush so you set up an
ambush on 50 yards of road or 30 yards
of road or whatever you put a bunch of
Claymores out and you're going to set up
this ambush in such a way so that when
an enemy Patrol four five six guys comes
walking through this thing you know that
at the right moment you can initiate
this Ambush cause an
explosion and it's gonna kill
most of the people but there's a little
area a little safe Zone in the middle of
the Ambush where someone's going to get
a concussion knocked out but they're
going to survive and then you can go
grab them and bring them home that's the
plan uh you you go on the insert fast
forward you go on the insert you you
conduct the uh the on day two you get
into a good ambushed position you've
been on a couple ambushed
positions and I'm going to go to the
book here suddenly I heard a group of
NVA open fire at Ambush site one
something scared them and they had open
fire randomly spraying bullets to both
sides of the trail some bullets were
coming our way the sounds were all AK-47
except one light machine gun they had a
machine gun the sound of the NVA ambush
in the sound of the NVA in Ambush site
one firing spooked the NVA in our Ambush
site it was decision time I had no way
to warn our team to close their eyes
because they were about to get hit with
a blast wave and debris it was too late
I simultaneously detonated the Claymores
in site one and the main Ambush site the
detonation was massive seven Claymores
five frag grenades four pounds of C4
and automatic weapons fire from the team
I was stunned by the blast wave from the
explosives debris branches rocks dirt
smoke a blast wave and sound hit me in
the face and blinded me the smell of
gunpowder and smoke was choking I
couldn't he I jerked a leech off my face
because you leeches crawling all over
you so that's what happens
boom seven Claymores five frag grenades
four pounds of C4 how far back off the
Ambush Trail were you how far do you
think you were from
the Maybe 15 meters or
something that's that's gonna ring your
bell oh
yeah but we had you know we had trees so
we had the Claymores in front of the
trees so that that helped some but some
of the blast is still going to come
around
it uh back to the book wait the team
wasn't firing why weren't they firing
were they knocked out temporarily
stunned the 6 to1 and again look I'm I'm
skipping ahead you got to read the book
to get the if some of this sounds like
oh what's that because there was
different Ambush sites you had them all
set up at the same time the details are
in the book get the book The 6 to 10 NVA
not in the Kill Zone were firing in
random directions then some of the team
began firing now the surviving NVA knew
where we were and directed their fire on
us they were gaining fire superiority
and we couldn't let that happen I empty
220 round magazines and tossed a frag
grenade I had to get everyone out and
returning fire quick quickly I yelled
Nash take him out Nash Pua and
rapon focused their fire on the NVA and
threw two frag grenades and a wiie Pete
grenade at them bullets were flying in
all directions the wiie Pak grenade
produced a shower of white phosphorous
chunks that fell on the live NVA burning
them severely and creating a very dense
white choking smoke it looked like some
of the chunks were going to hit us but
they didn't the smoke provided temporary
concealment of the Kill Zone and in some
incapacitation of the NVA Nash Pua and
rupon fired into the dense smoke and
into the Kill Zone most of the team
dashed onto the trail to make sure all
the NVA except the prisoners were dead
and searched two of the three NVA that
had been in the near been in or near the
hole were on their hands and knees the
third was trying to stand up barsell got
there first and quickly body slammed the
one trying to get up then pounced on the
other I took the third Chong and catua
cantua jumped on the prisoner as soon as
they hit the ground got the cuffs on
them drugged gagged and headb agged them
while the other guys were finishing off
the NVA in the Kill Zone and searching
them AA is that right aa aa was standing
in the Kill Zone providing
security so the explosion goes off
there's a little hesitation while you
guys are getting your bearings back now
you start shoot sure enough the plan
worked cuz in the middle of this Kill
Zone there was an area where there was
three prisoners that
were dazed but alive yeah and sounds
like they weren't wounded either which
is
good the Clock Was ticking we had to get
out of the Kill Zone suddenly the first
group of NVA that had gone through the
Ambush came running back down the trail
and opened fire on us now we were the
ones now we were the ones in the Kill
Zone 18
was hit immediately in the abdomen and
went down I was on the ground wrestling
with the prisoner and was splattered
with A's blood he began yelling hit
hit I turned and shot one of the three
one of the three with a four round burst
cantua quickly terminated the other two
then sat on the prisoner on prisoner
three while I dragged AA out of the Kill
Zone he was bleeding badly and his
intestines were hanging out he was in
tremendous pain and screaming I slowed
A's bleeding and got his intestines
contained in his abdomen I injected him
with morphine got on the radio cantua
maintained control of prisoner 3 cvy
Charlie 5 Alpha India which meant Ambush
initiated one brunette which is wounded
three Papa whiskies prisoners heavy
contact moving to Lima Zulu which is the
LZ over Roger Charlie 5 Charlie 5 two
cobras five mics out Echo Hotel
extraction helicopters standing
by so at this point you've got these
guys
um some of the NVA ran up from the
trail heavy they put out a heavy volume
of fire you have another guy get wounded
Chong gets wounded he gets
hit this is
freaking getting getting gnarly quick um
well it was you know we wouldn't have
ambushed that
group if the ones coming behind them
hadn't reacted down at that first ambush
site and spooked these guys yeah so we
had to set it off so everybody everybody
wasn't in the Kill Zone right you know
and there were more people than we had
planned to do but sometimes you don't
have that option to not do something so
we had to go ahead and set it off and
and do the best that we could and then
that first little group that went went
through went up a but they turned and
and came running back down and you know
by that time we were out in the Kill
Zone searching bagging all that stuff so
yeah it um got a little gnarly
there fast forward a little bit we had
three prisoners handcuffed behind their
backs gagged headbed drugged and secured
with ankle
ropes this was an 8ft rope we tied to
one ankle so we could jerk their foot
and cause them to face plan if they
tried to run a fourth group of
approximately 25 to 30 NVA came up the
trail and engaged Nash and Pua pu was
rapidly firing 40 MIM high explosive
rounds at the NVA causing them to take
cover this fourth group seemed to be
increasing in number we tried to escape
down the slope toward the LZ but they
were gaining on us we couldn't move fast
with the prisoners fighting us every
step of the way to slow us down they
kept throwing themselves on the ground
and fighting to prevent us from getting
them up and move moving barsell carried
AA or Ada Nash assisted Chung and
returned fire I yelled to Nash to help
Pua and put out some Claymores with time
fuse to slow down our pursuers I took
control of prisoner 3 from Pua he put
out a claymore with a Time fuse a group
of NVA ran in front of the Claymore Kill
Zone just as it detonated it ripped a
hole through their assault line and
shredded them while we were trying to
regroup another Claymore detonated
hitting a few more of them the second
blast really increased their fear of
chasing us but they did it anyways they
move slower however and we hesitant to
get too close to us Pua put several 40
mm rounds in and around them in R rapid
succession and slowed them down cvy
Charlie 5 where are the snakes we need
them now they're just coming on station
and the snakes is the uh
cobras Roger cvy 30 seconds out get your
heads down I yelled to my team cobras
coming in everyone get down protect your
head some of the bullets were stopped in
the high up in the trees with some of
the 40 mm but most were getting through
and hitting some some of the NVA it was
difficult for the bullets to get through
the triple canopy this is five good run
good run do it again there was a loud
boom and a flash that cvy saw from the
air Nash made his way to rapon and
prisoner 2 to see how badly they were
injured he yelled prisoner 2 is dead
rapun has strapped on his leg and arm
bleeding can't walk I've got him Nash
make sure prisoner 2 is dead and leave
him we got to go I yelled back this is
five crap they just took out prisoner 2
with an RPG and we've got another
brunette that can't walk wait out this
is five marking position again ID color
I've got a white flare Roger that make
it make the Run 50 m south of my
position flying east to west danger
close do it
now and again this is the kind of stuff
that you're doing right now because
you're a lot better at it than you were
when you on your first mission oh
yeah the NVA had masked about 20 M out
from us and were assaulting take cover
they are assaulting us throw some
grenades switch to Auto Pua put some 40
mm on them I I shouted they were
dropping like flies but more were coming
I was firing from behind a tree and just
as I finished a magazine I saw an NVA 5
feet from coua whose weapon was empty
and prisoner three I drew my Colt 45 and
shot at the NVA Soldier twice the impact
of the bullets literally picked him up
off the ground and threw him backwards
wow 45 hits hard don't let them get away
keep firing I reloaded and got a couple
more of them as they were retreating so
did koua koua lead us to the LZ I'm a
I'm a little busy cvy I yelled back over
the heavy volume of gunfire explosions
and me yelling something about nv's
ancestors in the
background this is five a group of NVA
just made the final assault of of their
lives put the first Napal 150 meters
south of my position flying east to west
danger close don't miss we are moving
towards the LZ I shouted Michigan get
down Napal 20 seconds out
the Napal hit the trees but a lot of it
came to the ground right on the NVA if
it gets on you it won't come off it just
sticks and burns the smoke was so thick
Under The Canopy our eyes were burning
and we couldn't see and we're having
trouble breathing the smell was
sickening Pua and prisoner one were both
throwing up I accidentally pressed the
push to talk button before I finished
talking to the team check ammo and
redistribute sorry cvy it's a little
chaotic down here put the second Napal
100 East of my position flying north
south to North Roger second Napal 30
seconds out get on the ground with
something between you and the Napal ASAP
I yelled Michigan on the ground Napal 20
seconds out cover your
head most of this one came to the ground
it was on the NVA but almost hit us this
stuff scared me take out the Torches I
shouted the Napal had burned away a lot
of the vegetation making it easier to
see the NVA and shoot them I kept saying
to myself this is the Humane thing to do
five get down third Napal 30 seconds out
Roger that it's barbecue
time Michigan get down Napal 20 seconds
out another good drop right on the NVA
the smell of overcooked human flesh
smoke and low oxygen air makes you want
to vomit I watched as coua and Chung
began throwing
up the Napal stopped the NVA advancement
toward us we grabbed the prisoners
barsell picked up AA Nash picked up
rapon and made a run for the LZ before
the NVA regrouped and came after us we
were only about 200 meters from the LZ I
put the last Napal between us and the LZ
to clear a path it definitely did that
quite a few of the charred bodies were
still burning as we moved through the
area the smell was gross there was
little oxygen in the air making it
difficult to breathe and it was very
smoky and burned our eyes we were
sweating so much it was running into our
eyes making it even more difficult to
see we moved as fast as we could with
the two prisoners fighting every step
and three wounded team members two of
whom were being carried we were all
soaking wet from the heat humidity
running fighting and dragging prisoners
we were dehydrated thirsty exhausted
running on pure adrenaline but getting
closer to the extraction
LZ two prisoners three
wounded and they you know the
prisoners they had rathered die than be
a prisoner MH they'd been indoctrinated
so much and told what all horrible
things we were going to do to them if if
we caught them so they would do anything
to prevent us from getting them you know
to the helicopter they' throw themselves
on the ground I mean they would take
your weapon they would do anything that
they could to try to stop it uh and at
the same time their guys are trying to
shoot them cuz they didn't want them to
go go out either so I mean they're
between a rock and a hard place they
think we're going to you know carve them
up and mutilate them their guys are
trying to shoot them they're the only
people in the world in a worse spot than
you guys were
yeah what drugs did you put in them
morphine just morphing them up
yeah going back to the book and we were
about a 100 met from the LZ we hit a
wall of withering AK RPG and RPD fire
boom Boom the Heat and blast wave from
the RPGs temporarily blinded
us Michigan get down use single shots
cvy we in heavy contact on the south
side of the LZ got any more Napal this
is cvy yes where you want it I want this
I want the center mass of the of I want
the center Mass to be 30 meters north of
the tree line on the south edge of the
LZ Fly East of West danger close
actually very close don't miss Roger
that stand by this is cvy the Gates of
Hell will open in 30 seconds get down
Roger Michigan get down Napal 20 seconds
out danger
close during those 20 seconds the NVA
fired an RPG close to prisoner 3 and hit
him with strael and peppered me with
shrapnel I could feel the heat and blast
from the RPG canu was with prisoner 3
prisoner 3 was bleeding badly I couldn't
do anything for him until after the
napom strike the napom hit very close
resulting in most of the team receiving
small burns the stuff was really scary
to use one miscalculation and the entire
team would be crispy
Critters I scrambled to prisoner 3 and
began trying to stop some of the
bleeding I looked up and saw a torch
coming toward me can to a take over but
not just any torch this one was dragging
an RPD by the barrel I hit him in the
chest with a three round burst from my
car 15 and the torch and machine gun
were gone all future Generations that
could come from him were instantly
erased
my pant leg was on fire I tried to Pat
that out but it just spread and got on
my glove now my glove was burning too
and it was hot I grabbed a handful of
mud and my glove went out I rubbed the
mud on my pant legs and put the flame
out it lit up again I put more mud on
and realized my shirt sleeve was burning
again I rubb mud on it to put it out
Napal was hard to
extinguish just it's like like that old
jod call about napom napom sticks Like
Glue I
mean can't get it off of
you this is five that was a little
closer than I
expected it fried the bad guys but we
have gotten some Burns and the suntan
through our clones we might even uh we
are ready to go home can you get us out
of here Roger that we have two birds on
Final Approach escorted by Cobra stand
by for extraction Roger we'll be wearing
orange hats expect a lot of ground fire
standing by Michigan turn turn your hats
orange I yelled to my team the first
load will be barwell Nash prisoner one
AA and Pua there'll be a lot of ground
fire we have to load faster they'll
leave it or or they will leave us keep
the prisoner
secured prisoner one resisted getting on
the helicopter until barwell punched him
in the jaw he staggered and dropped to
his knees barsell grabbed him and threw
him in the helicopter it seemed like it
took a long time to load the wounded my
job was to provide supporting fire
barwell and Nash were doing a great job
loading the wounded without injuring
them they finally they fin they were
finally in and lifting off I could hear
the metallic clangs of bullets hitting
their Chopper the second aircraft was on
short final I had the wounded prisoner 3
cantua Chong and rapon with me we were
receiving a lot of fire but our prisoner
3 was not resisting cantua and I helped
the others get aboard what and we lifted
off about 2 minutes after bars Well's
aircraft the ground fire was still
coming at us and the helicopter received
several hits as we were leaving I
dropped a red smoke grenade the Cobras
were ripping the area around the L apart
with Min guns 40 mm and Rockets spads
were working more naom 250lb bombs and
20 20 mm machine guns higher and lower
on the ridge trying to interdict the
flow of troops on the ridgel line to
suppress the ground fire as I watched
the firework show around us I took a
deep breath let it out slowly and
thought we just might make it out of
here cvy this is five thanks we really
appreciate you what you guys did for us
today outstanding job we'll take you
care of you back at the ranch I sat back
to relax a few few minutes later I was
looking at bars Well's helicopter in
front of us and thinking that although
the team was banged up pretty badly it
was it was a success it was a successful
Mission we got out with two
prisoners then it happened I saw a body
fall from barw Well's helicopter I had
on a headset so I was able to ask our
pilot how high we were and would he ask
the lead aircraft what happened he told
me we were at 2,300 feet AGL and
apparently the prisoner had got loose
and Dove out of the helicopter still
handcuffed and head bagged he was last
seen as he disappeared head first into
the jungle canopy 2300 ft below
traveling somewhere between 160 and 180
miles per
hour
so um you get back with your prisoner
and he dies as well
died on the table just you know if you
get hit in the legs or the the arms you
know you can use tarnet there things you
can do you can stop the bleeding but you
know if you're hit you know and your
torso I mean you just can't get there
easily to stop the bleeding and
eventually you're going to bleed out
so you guys were not not good with your
a
prisoner no
no that's a tough freaking Mission I
mean it's hard enough to go and kill
them but to go not kill them and try and
bring them back as they're
resisting there I mean there are ways to
do it um I mean lot of teams brought
prisoners back yeah they did it um I
mean you were close you got two on the
birds
yeah and
um yeah I'm sure some of it's me because
I had opportunities you'll seeing book
too that um it just didn't work
out but
um yeah is that where you got your
second nickname
Terminator it was beginning to build up
the the name really didn't come about
until you know several years later okay
with another group but people had known
me or knew about me and some things
happened and you
know I got a different code
name and this is before this is before
the movie terminated just so you know
Echo Charles impressive this is this is
where the Terminator got their name for
their movie right oh yeah uh some of the
Lessons Learned you got here needed more
practice securing a violently resisting
prisoner loaded with
adrenaline uh another one trying to
communicate during a firefight
especially if we are trying to escape is
very difficult need to have Americans in
the right places to relay
commands need more medical training
especi or medical training especially
controlling
bleeding you have a a a psychological
Lessons Learned on this one we need to
stay busy between missions inactivity
allows fear to creep in what was that
all
about when you have you know a really
tough Mission like a couple of these
here um it Spooks the team as they think
about it if if you just give them time
off and let them go drink and party do
whatever they want to
do then you know those fears can start
to come
in so I I started trying to keep them
busy and then later on in in book two uh
Lynn black you know had the the same
thoughts so he and I got together
and found some interesting things to
do interesting things to do between
missions just to you know yeah you say
what's one of your other lessons related
to it there's a de there's a direct
relation between time between missions
and level of
fear and then at the same also you say
we need time to heal physically and
psychologically between missions so you
need to be you need time but you need to
to say busy during that time yeah yeah
um we need time between missions to
correct problems and train for the next
one the physical and psychological
effects of wearing a headset was
stunning in addition to providing so I
didn't mention this part but you this is
one of the missions where you first wore
a headset inside the helicopter which
means you could hear Communications in
the helicopter and you weren't getting
your ears people have no idea how loud
it is in a freaking helicopter like if
you watch a movie people you see people
like talking in a helicopter no there's
not you can't you have you have to get
in someone's ear and
yell so uh you say in addition to
providing real-time Battlefield
information also gave me the ability to
adapt the insertion plan while we were
still in the air have more control of
the insertion manage fear focus and
relax be fully in the game before
arrival at LZ and preserve hearing now
and in the
future yeah so you know one of the
things like preserve hearing like you
were just talking about so loud in the
aircraft that when you get off and run
into the jungle and and you go do your
security
halt your eyes adjust your smell adjust
all of those things adjust your ears
take can take several hours before you
get all of your hearing back now did you
guys even have like you know the little
foamy things to stick in your ears or
anything like
that
yes but
we had been programmed those were for
the range protect your hearing on the
Range now after I left some smart guys
said why don't we wear those things on
the helicopter we can take them out when
we when we go off to helicopter we take
them out put them in our pocket so you
know General boray uh I mean his group
did it all the time mhm you know he came
about 3 months after after I left and
you know some smart guys had said put
them in your ears yeah take them out
when you get there you you refer a lot
of the in the book to the blinding flash
of the obvious yeah oh yeah that's one
of them right there so I mean I was so I
was so impressed by what I could do with
that headset before I got on the ground
how much adaptation I could do um how
much it helped me just to remain focused
um
yeah I mean that that was great and then
if you look around now I mean all the
operators M have headsets yeah and that
go with them when they get on the ground
yeah you know so you can hear each other
talk and everything and you have
enhanced hearing because it can amplify
the sound there's all kinds of things it
cuts off um you know an 85 dbel of a gun
fire so I mean just super but before
that you got out the helicopter treating
you
death yeah I can't I can't imagine what
your hearing sounded like but yeah we
we'd go in that security hall and sit
there for 15 minutes and think yeah we
got it now we can hear man could
hear uh you mentioned this before but I
here it is again Napal Napal puts the
fear of God or maybe the devil in the
NVA it is the most horrible cruel
terrifying physically and
psychologically damaging weapon in our
Arsenal it creates a lot of human
torches enemy soldiers covered with
burning Napal blindly stumbling around
as they are being consumed by fire the
enemy survivors if there are any never
get over the screams smells pain lack of
oxygen in the air choking air smoke and
visual images they see the experiences
literally burned into their brains and
Minds
the the team that delivers the Napal
never gets over the experience calling
it in scares me because I know the
slightest miscalculation by anyone in
the process can cause it to hit the good
guys all of the team received some Burns
this time but sometimes you have to
choose to save the team at all
costs what's up with the uh the lack of
oxygen in the air so the the Napal Burns
and it burns all the oxy it has to have
the oxygen in the air to to burn and so
it it literally makes it hard to breathe
it just takes takes it out so I mean
you're you're you're sucking in
nitrogen but you're not getting the
oxygen that you need to breathe so you
know it choking you're taking a breath
but you don't feel like you you got any
air you're
suffocating um and you know if you're
right there in the middle of it those
guys don't get any yeah it's all gone
but just around it you know it's the air
has a lot less oxygen in it this one
that burn you guys like the one that's
on your sleeve it hit your sleeve and
pant leg how far were you from that
impact it was supposed to be like 100
150 M or
so but when it hit the canopy it
scatters and it it goes all
over and you know it was just
a little too close to
us but it's I mean if you if you've ever
watched them drop those things
it's you know it's in a a
canister it's not like a bomb it's just
in a long canister and when they release
it and they turn it loose tumbles it
just
tumbles and how they get as accurate
with it as they do I don't know because
it's just tumbling and then you know
when it goes into the trees first real
hard limb big limb it hits it breaks the
canature and and it sets it off if
you're dropping it out in a relatively
open area you know it tumbles and it
hits pretty close to where it's supposed
to be it has a nice burn pattern when it
comes
out but you know I in fact I saw
um a discussion on Facebook I think it
was last week in people were saying um
that anybody up
north use
napon because of the
canopy and most people were saying I
don't I don't know how you could and I
said I did all the time but but you you
know you you take a real chance you have
to put it further away it's going to
scatter you have to know that
um yeah I mean for something to be to
smell so bad that guys are puking while
they're in combat yeah I mean from it's
just the charred flesh the burning flesh
it just puts out such a smell that it
just invokes that vomit response and you
know people start to
vomit another lesson learned you got
here the the prisoners fought us the
whole time and really slowed our
movement especially Under Fire they made
they also made loading the aircraft
difficult barsell had to knock out his
prisoner to get him on the helicopter
and he still managed to jump out this
was a very mentally and physically
fatiguing operation start to finish we
needed more physical
training
um you also talk about barsell which you
mentioned already today that that he he
had seen that RPD and really wanted to
start using that that belt-fed machine
gun and uh first lieutenant Ken bow Bor
b b Bor Bor another guy that uh
became a major general yeah who also
carried that as person weapon car
actually bargewell gave him his his RPD
okay so you know I look back at that and
I say well geez barsell carried that
thing and he became a major general the
lieutenant he gave it to became a major
general I should have said give it to me
let me try may give me the lucky gun but
then I go back and look n you know those
two guys are
good yeah cause too much
trouble
um now at this juncture in in the
deployment for you I I don't know if
this is considered a break or not but
you guys get put on marble Mountain
security for 10 days this is is it is
this considered downtime for you guys
supposed to be a break supposed to be a
break uh there's two basically there's a
big outside uh CCN there's a there's a
mountain range Marble mountain and you
guys put two different combat outposts
on top of those so that the enemy
couldn't get him and fire down into you
and so you guys would rotate up there
and this is the compound this is the
compound that got overrun or nearly
overrun 23 August 1968 the 17 SF guys
were killed and one of the reasons it
got nearly overrun was because they G
they gave up The High Ground the enemy
Took The High Ground
so you guys put combat Outpost up there
to prevent that from happening again and
you guys get this tasking to go up there
so
um you get up there and I mean
it's here's a here's here's what we're
dealing with the sunset was beautiful
from the combat Outpost but it was a l
before the storm around 2030 we came
under heavy fire from the small Plateau
between us and combat Outpost 2 this
gave me an opportunity to play with my
M60 machine gun I engaged the enemy with
a heavy barrage of 762 was joined by the
M60 on Cop 2
it was nice not to have to carry the
heavy M60 or the
ammo um you guys start doing uh a ARS
after each day during the a we noticed
that the sandbags around our position
had not fared well during the attack
barsell put in a request for 50 full
sandbags along with more ammunition to
be delivered by lunch we also discussed
the following and you got a bunch of
things that
we that you put in here that you dealt
with and one of them is this kind of
claustrophobic feeling that you got
I had become so used to shooting and
moving that my position felt almost
claustrophobic on the peak we could not
maneuver so this is a new feeling for
you
yeah and you don't like it very much uh
nowhere to
go uh you say in hindsight I find it
difficult to believe we did not wear
helmets and FL jackets in this static
position which is definitely you get up
there and you don't have to carry them
anywhere but you're not don't have
them um
fast forward a couple days day three
around 11:00 on day three the talk
called and said I needed a report to
Recon company talk a visitor was waiting
for me that was all they would say I
took cantuna and hang and we made our
way down the mountain I was in total
shock when I saw who was waiting for me
it was my cousin Carl from the Thompson
Rangers this is when you were a kid I
knew he was in country on his third tour
in Vietnam but did not expect to see him
out at while I was out at CCN I
especially did not to expect to see him
inside a top secret SOG compound that
few people outside of SOG knew existed
how did he know I was there and how did
he talk his way into a restricted
compound he' always amazed me with that
with what he could do he said he had a
few days leave from golf company 75th
Rangers and came up to see me I
explained that my team was securing the
cop and I had to go back up there but if
he didn't mind getting shot at while he
was on leave I could show him a good
time he was all in we ate in the mess
hall and then we went to the supply room
where he signed for a car 15 some
tactical gear Ruck lurs ammo and an IV
of ringer solution Poncho and a liner he
declined the helmet and Flack jacket and
we headed up the mountain it was great
to see him and serve in combat for a few
days together like we did when we were
kids I would have felt better if he had
taken the helmet and Flack jacket
because this time the bad guys would be
shooting back with AK-47s and RPGs the
enemy did not disappoint us they
attacked several times during the night
I think they knew we had a new person
with us on the mountain and wanted to
welcome Cousin
Carl so he takes leave and his leav is
to go how did he tell you how he found
you how'd he find you he never really
divulged his sources but I mean he you
know once he was out of the service he
became a a car
salesman if you stop by his car lot to
ask him for direction somewhere he'd s
you a car he leaveing with a car
yeah he could talk in anybody into
anything then somehow he talked his way
in to a top secret
compound that mean it was
Unreal
um day four you guys are up there you
start getting a little bored so what do
you doing your board you go out and
start clearing caves there's caves on
these on this mountain
um this was interesting you're clearing
one of these caves we did not find
anyone in the cave across from us but we
did see a lot of dried blood when we
went into the one of the lower caves we
surp to NVA Carl put one of them down
right away then we started dodging our
own bullets cuz you're shooting around
in a rock cave we were educated on what
happens when you start shooting in a
stone cave Ricochet each bullet was
bouncing off two or three walls before
it stopped after a few minutes we got
the hang of it and took out the other
bad guy we searched them and left their
bodies outside the cave and returned to
cop one Campa thought we should put the
two NBA's heads on Stakes as a warning
to the other NVA I told him to re sheep
this knife we're not going to do that he
and po are not happy
they they wanted to do some
psychological operations put them on a
steak
uh fast forward a couple more days um
about 1300 this is day six 1300 hang in
CA ask if they could make a quick run
down to the Village no trouble they said
H said they would be back in an hour
barsell agreed and said they could go
but they needed they had to take coua
Pua and the radio with them 20 minutes
later 20 minutes after they left we
heard two car5 gun shots followed
immediately by kantu on the radio saying
no problem we come home barsell said
they've done something I can hear in
kant's voice uh turns out they went to
uh some kind of I guess some kind of
Monastery about halfway up there was a
monastery and they shot a monk dog what
the monks had a dog had a dog they shot
him and came back into camp and says
monk dog they eat barell almost lost it
he had he shared some very heated words
with Hayne and Canoa
Cana to interpret them barell was not
happy with them they had killed the
Monk's dog and they were going to eat
it the evening meal was dog and
rice bargewell Carl and I had Lars
actual Carl did have a small portion of
dog with rice just to maintain the team
Bond day seven
a we spent time on no heads on sticks
and no eating monks
dogs those were the debrief points
um well you know Mountain yards some and
some Vietnamese you know they love the
dog but if you saw a mountain
yard squeezing a dog kind of the feeling
of it that thing's done it was going to
disappear and
they they were going to eat
it all right but we briefed them we
can't put any heads on Stakes and we
can't eat the monks dogs couple days
later just after 2100 a large group of
NVA open fire on both cops with AK-47s
and RPGs from the back side of the
plateau couple of b40 rockets went over
the cop and down toward CCN compound but
hit short of the defensive wire called
for flares from the mortar Crews at the
same time this was happening a marine
Compound on the other side of the
village was attacked we could see a
heavy exchange of fire marines called
155 mm artillery to help defend their
position with our cops lit up five
flares the snipers decided to join the
party then a second group of NVA open
fire from positions much closer to us
they had the dark night to slip in
closer than normal we were definitely
slugging it out with them after about 20
minutes while communicating back and
forth with the SSG with with uh staff
sergeant Saunders on Cop 2 over the
radio I slipped in a comment that if we
had a case of beer we'd be having a real
party up
here so then fast forward the end of
that gunfight while observing the
absence of bodies in The Talk The Talk
called for an update to let me know the
CC the CCN Commander wanted me to report
to his office at
0800 when I got to Lieutenant Colonel I
eisler's office he confronted me about
the drinking and partying going on at my
cop I assured him that was not the case
he said he heard me say if I had another
case of beer I told him that a case of
beer was just banter while was pinned
down in fighting position not able to
return
fire uh his final words were no party
being on the mountain I said yes
sir did a quick a
AR even though we were going back to CCA
I discussed being careful about what was
said on the radio coua inserted Colonel
like NVA always
[Laughter]
listen oh that was uh that was classic I
I actually always had a roll out no
joking on the radio that was a rule that
I had I had seen a couple I had one of
my officers
he was we were on a ship Navy ship and
on a Navy ship there's something called
navy red which is like what every ship
you know every Navy ship is listening to
and for some reason we were in the
bridge of the ship and we were talking
to my lieutenant Junior grade was
talking to like our commander on another
on the mother
ship and he was my young Lieutenant was
pissed about something that we were
getting told to do and so over this he
says Whiskey Tango Fox tro
over and he got in a he got in trouble
for that one um and so I from that time
on I made a rule it's like no never joke
around on the radio so uh can't be
asking for that extra case of
beer uh Lessons
Learned you say being in a static
defensive fighting position is different
they know exactly where you are than a
team fighting and maneuvering sandbags
got shredded very quickly snipers get
your attention be careful what you say
on the radio eating the monks dogs did
not make the monks happy it's a good
lesson
learned
uh mission
three Search and
Destroy RT Michigan's mission was to
search find and destroy an NVA
regimental unit
so now we're going after 2,000 men
operating near the LA North Vietnam
border you insert by the king
bees you say this I could smell decomp
in the air soon CA signaled that he
smelled it too we found a day old
partially eaten deer koua said
tigers that got everyone's attention
this this was a yard team they grew up
in the jungle and were very familiar
with what tigers could do to a human CA
became even more
Vigilant within two hours after our
insertion we heard bamboo clackers being
used by trackers and a muffled dog bark
we were not expecting dogs dogs or
Tigers a few minutes later Pua found
tiger
scat around TW fast forward you're
you're in your layup position for the
around 2200 we heard a muffled dog bark
and Yelp about 100 meters from us can
Tua whispered tiger eat dog this number
10 not
good I knew no one would sleep that
night this is this is a little uh I
picked that up from tilt from tilt like
the one through
10 this is number 10 not
good as bad as it's GNA get freaking
Tigers out there and you got a picture
of a tiger in the book and it is look at
this Echo Charles and that's actually a
small one you can tell it's small but
I'll tell you what his teeth aren't
small oh yeah that
horrifying that thing looks horrifying
um a
tiger a full grown tiger can take your
head off with one
swipe just decapitate you they can reach
into a fighting position and and they
were documented cases where a lot of
Marines were in the fighting positions
at night and a tiger came by reached in
grabbed a hold of him drag him out and
ran off in the jungle with God I was in
Sri Lanka when there was a civil war
going on over in Sri Lanka and we were
working with their special operations
group but they said that the
Tigers would
swim into
the like close Coastal Waters and grab
fishermen out of their
boats uh so that's what we're dealing
with here
um you you you eventually you start
putting in air strikes uh and once you
guys once you guys start putting in air
strikes because the accuracy of the air
strikes the NVA know that you're there
and so now they start stepping up their
patrols they really start looking for
you fast forward a little bit you guys
are trying to get away um and then
you're you're hold up and going to the
book around 3:30 we heard a tiger get a
dog and its Handler the Handler's scream
was scary as the NVA continued to get
closer to finding us we got lucky cuvy
brought in an a C130 Spectre gunship
that could link to our Spectre
transponder and shoot all around us
without having to Mark our position with
flares or strobe BLS the NVA could see
technology was continuing to enhance
sog's SOG RT's Mission
abilities so you heard a tiger then
freaking kill a dog in its
Handler does the does the tiger make
noise or no just hear the dog whimpering
and screaming and then you hear a man
screaming and whimpering they're very
you know they're nocturnal Hunters
they're very quiet it's it's amazing as
big as they are they don't make any
noise you know
and and
um I deal with this on a regular basis
because I a feral cat has decided I'm
his new BFF but but
anyway they hunt at night um but they
have um excellent night vision because
the there's a membrane in their eyes
that causes the light to reflect around
and it gives them this enhanced night
vision and that's why if you shine a
light on a an animal that has that great
night vision their eyes show up I mean
they just light up like a deer a raccoon
um a cat their eyes you know just like
spotlights almost um and they can see
and and they have um much higher
frequency hearing than a dog so like a a
house cat feral cat I mean they can hear
those little squeaks little tiny sounds
that mice and other animals that they
eat make they can track those things
down I came home from work the other day
and walked into the garage and my cat's
all laying back in the garage like he
ons the place and laying in front of him
is a half of a rat
MH so he honored Me by get giving me
half of his rat and they do that showing
the respect
yeah why was this area a different AO
where these Tigers were yeah I mean they
they they hunted a pretty good size area
but um I mean rarely did my teams ever
you know encounter them MH we would see
there was a another place I don't
remember exactly where it was now but a
place where you could see that um they
had cut down big um pieces of bamboo and
really sharpen the ends of them and put
them in the ground so they would point
it out like that just kind of made a
like a a fence around the area to try to
keep the Tigers from coming in because
they'd walk into the
bamboo but you know but we didn't didn't
see any actual tigers or any evidence
besides that that fence and Ne here but
this one we did we saw the scat we saw
the the carus we heard the dog you know
being the eaten the the Handler but it's
quick you know their their preference is
to grab you by the back of the neck and
just and run off with it they they can
drag a huge animal off yeah I've seen
some video of them just
light work of
anything uh fast forward a little bit by
0400 we were in heavy contact and had to
declare prair Prairie Fire emergency and
bring in close air support to help us
try and get out to our extraction LZ it
soon became evident we we could not
survive to get to the LZ we adapted our
plan to be extracted by strings we had
to put on Swiss seats while we were in
our remain overnight just in case we
could not get to the LZ at first light
we were extracted by strings while the
whole area was pounded by Napal and
cluster bomb units from f4s and Rockets
Min guns and 40 mm
grenades from cobras so we had
learned from that other experience put
your Swiss seed on first yeah if you
think you might have to use it put that
thing on yeah now you know later later
on um the stabo rig was created so I
mean that was your harness you wor of
things so you had one on all the time
you didn't have to start tying a rope
around
you
um next
mission pipeline
destruction and Monkey
Business uh RT Michigan was assigned the
mission of finding a high volume fuel
pipeline coming out of North Vietnam and
running to fuel points along the hoochi
man Trail highway and destroying a
section of it we made an early even
evening insertion security halt then
moved quickly to a predetermined R
position two venomous snakes were
discovered during our movement to ro we
also heard trackers with clackers who
picked up our Trail all conditions were
right for this to be a long night our
plan was to find the pipeline before
going after the trackers at
approximately 2,300 a 10-man NVA search
team walked within 8 ft of our
perimeter there were several close calls
of the NVA who got closer to the
pipeline around 1600 on Day 2 we found
the pipeline everything went great until
0130 then we heard movement between us
and the cliffs as they got closer the
size of the group seemed to grow to
Squad size then platoon and finally
company size between 120 and 130 I
called Moonbeam and requested support
Moonbeam found a spectre gunship in the
range of our position and diverted it to
us Spectre flew several passes between
us and the cliff we could hear the
screams as over over 120 millimeter he
rounds hit the ground beside us and the
side of the
cliffs you had to see the impact of
those rounds to comprehend the Firepower
in less than 10 seconds a spectre gun
ship could put 12 mm Hy round in every
square yard of a football field-sized
area there were a few moans and groans
for a while then silence Spectre had
done its job we got a big surprise as we
moved out at daylight the jungle around
us was littered with with bodies and
body
parts of big
Apes there had been no definitive proof
of Rock Apes people like creatur
standing six feet tall but these were
really big Apes when asked for an
estimated body count I replied
40 so it's just a big herd of monkeys
big monkeys apes and and they will
attack we'd had SOG teams overrun by
them before and they they come through
they beat you up
they beat you up as they come through
and they take your
stuff they rob
you well these aren't going to get away
with it yeah I thought they were in VA
uhhuh and you know it was dark we
couldn't see I could hear them coming
and you know i' got to get them out of
here so I put Spectre on them and then
the next day I saw what was out there
and I thought holy cow I am not telling
them they shot a bunch of monkeys
um when we arrived at the pipeline I
noticed I notified cvy we were on target
waiting on the security patrol when the
patrol arrived barsell and I quickly
terminated the NVA using our 22 caliber
pistols with integrated silencers our
designated security team moved into
place while the rest set up the charges
we then activated the time fuse with 20
minutes burning time and quickly moved
100 meters to a second spot on the
pipeline placed our second charge and
ignited a 5iv minute time fuse we we
then began moving quickly toward the
extraction LZ I left toe poppers along
our path as we moved the
220b C4 charges made tremendous
explosions letting the fuel run out on
the ground the wiie Pete grenades made
sure the fuel ignited it was an awesome
fireworks display we heard one set of
toe poppers explode and knew the NVA
were close to us then we ran into a
group of 20 who seemed to be unhappy
fortunately by this time cvy had f4s on
station following our targeting
directions hit the pipeline in more
places with a mixture of H and Napal
their strikes produced secondary
explosions at the refueling stations a1s
provided close air support for the for
RT Michigan which was now in a prairie
fire
emergency after about two hours of
difficult fighting we were extracted
under heavy fire the mission was a
success we did not lose
anyone there you
go RT Michigan mission five be bomb
damage
assessment RT Michigan's mission was to
follow closely behind a B-52 strike in
LA and assess the bomb damage collect
intelligence from bodies and take a
prisoner if
possible so you guys launch on this
Mission with the exception of the smoke
rough air fires across the target area
and what looked like the aftermath of a
level five hurricane we were able to get
into our insertion
LZ it took a little longer than normal
to acclimate our senses as we neared the
target box trees were scattered all
around and there were lots of bomb
craters throughout the area over 300
bombs 75 tons of explosives and shrapnel
had been dropped in the Target
box we took pictures of the damage body
parts and bodies everything was surreal
as we consciously moved toward the
center of the target box fast forward to
day two we made heavy contact with an
NVA company-sized Force as the NVA
initially Drew with with Drew they left
a concussed NVA Soldier behind we were
all over him he was quickly put in a
flack jacket and helmet gagged headb
backed handcuffed and lightly sedated
with morphine the NVA realized we were a
small group and it captured one of their
people they regrouped and assaulted us I
called cvy and told them we had a we had
a prisoner and we were in heavy contact
we we were declaring a prairie fire
emergency and moving toward the
extraction LZ it seemed strange but we
could already hear the extraction
helicopter approaching I told cvy we
were approximately 100 met from the LZ
but moving very slowly he might want to
have a helicopter circle around and come
back cvy said our helicopter was still
45 minutes out from the LZ that did not
make sense it began to rain harder as we
continued to fight our way toward the LZ
then we saw a group of NVA running to
the LZ in front of us with a tall
soldier D in a dressed in a different
type of uniform running with them I
could not get a good camera shot I told
cvy there was another team with us the
tall guy looked Chinese a Strang looking
helicopter not us not Vietnamese popped
out of the clouds down to the LZ and a
few seconds later it was back up into
the clouds with people on it the
pictures I took of the men running
toward the LZ and the aircraft lifting
off were blurred and cloudy when
reviewed later we weren't able to
determine the nationality of the man or
origin of the aircraft we remained in
contact with the a1s to pound attackers
for an hour before we were extracted the
team was tired and hungry and eager to
get back to CCN we boarded the king B
and bounced all over the sky in a bad
weather on the way home our prisoner
bled out on the way back 2 AK 47 rounds
went through the Flack jacket and
penetrated his
lungs they want they would not stop
bullets not an AK oh no and it sounds
like the enemy was most certainly aiming
to kill those guys almost as a priority
over killing you guys yeah
um and I'll close out the book with this
section
here says it was a relief to get back to
CCN we had been promised a two-day RNR
starting the next day no new missions
for two days and we needed it at this
point I had completed nine across the
fence SOG missions as well as some
in-country missions we were looking
forward to cleaning up eating and
starting recovery I knew that within a
couple of hours I would have a full
stomach and be sleeping like a baby
barsell and I would do a quick a and
Lessons Learned with the team right
after breakfast then the next morning
and then let them go for a couple of
days when we landed barsell and I
cleaned up and met at the mess hall to
eat and do our quick a we finished
eating around 1930 and went back to our
rooms I did a quick clean and reload of
my car 15 and webgear and laid down
across my bed then I heard a loud knock
at my door followed by Lieutenant
Thompson are you in there yes what do
you want when he told me I said you got
to be kidding me no sir 2000 hours
that's 8 minutes from now careful what
you say sir he's just on the other side
of your plywood
wall
crap just another day in
SOG to be
continued well give us an indication
what were you being asked for you get
back from a mission what are they saying
to
you they're
saying we have a new company Recon
company
Commander a guy named captain
Meadows and he wants to meet with you at
2000 and the the way the hooches are set
up they were divided in the center so
you know you had people living on each
side so on the other end of my hood
uh turned out to be now you know the new
Recon company commander and I was living
on this side and there's a little
plywood wall between us so you know my
room maybe the size about the size of
this room normally there would be two
guys here two guys over on that side but
right now I didn't I didn't have anybody
in there with me I hadn't had it to
myself and I forgot who was over there
but they went away and now the new
company Commander is over there
and he wanted to see me everybody knew
the name and and the reputation of this
guy so I thought holy cow you know what
does he
want I really wanted to go to
bed and now I've got a new boss and he
wants to see
me well um and like I said the book ends
with to be continued I I know a little
bit about what happens because you know
the first time you were on the podcast
but again the uh details that you put
inside these books is next level um but
I know you're about to get promoted
right that's what's about to
happen my job is about to change
y um so the next book is the next book
ready already is it coming out when's it
coming out should be out around October
October
and uh what are you done with the
writing of it are you just doing the
editing now yeah we're just doing the
editing how has the how has the book
writing been for you look you wrote I
know you've written what five or six
books but these were the first ones that
were dedicated to your combat
experience this one the stress effect
yep um went fast
um
enjoyable this is the hardest thing I've
ever written and you know we were
talking about it when I was here three
years ago yeah um it didn't
and you know it's it's about me
personally whereas the stress effects
has a lot of examples and things in it
but but this is about what I saw what I
experienced the people I knew um
and I had to go back 50 plus years to
get the
information um a lot of the guys uh were
gone so I couldn't ask them in some
cases um some people
said could you give me a different
name I I don't want to go back there I
left it way back then I want it to stay
back then I don't I don't want people
contacting me and saying you know I saw
your name in the book um so there are a
lot of different things like that
emotional things with the book so it
just took a lot longer and then you know
sag was um a top secret organization and
when it when it ended in
72 for the most part every all the
records and things are
destroyed so it it's difficult to go
back and and find
information and I I realized I had kept
some you know timelines and stuff um but
when I started to do this and went and
started looking for
things you know like I mentioned before
everybody's Tombstone says Vietnam
that's not where they
died but some of the dates are wrong I
mean I got awards for things that the
date on the award de match up with the
date these guys supposedly died you know
during during this you know particular
battle and sty um so trying to get a
timeline that's relatively accurate you
know was difficult that took a long time
and I finally got to the point where I'm
going to get it as close as I can get it
and if somebody wants to argue over a
week or two or something like that on
when a particular event happened you
know that's fine you know I'm telling
the story this is what I saw and even if
the dates are a little off um so it was
it was difficult and then you know I I
wrote the whole
year about it and realized then you know
I had a book twice that
size and was was telling you know it it
doesn't fit in the you know the $20
range so you got to do something so they
recommended i' I'd make two books out of
it you know so the whole thing was
written but because I put this one
out separately and first I just have to
adjust some things in in the second
one you know rewrite some things like
the
preference this is a nice preference for
the book but since that one's already
done and now we're doing something else
and the other I need a different
preference to lead into you know where
did this come from why why are we doing
it like this
um but yeah it'll be out I uh I think it
will get people's
attention yeah I mean
there's there's some pretty hairy
missions coming up there's some missions
that were
just one of a kind in terms of things
that happen yeah that uh you know
shocked people when we talked about it
on the podcast yeah and in the greater
detail right it's going to shock them
you know a little bit more no I'm I'm
definitely looking forward to uh getting
the rest of the detail and hearing some
of those um I mean some of those are
just you know they're they're they're
they're truly unbelievable in about
seven different aspects
you know the decision- making process
the chances the luck the skill The
Bravery the the outcomes um it I mean
you can say this about you know just
about every Mission you went on you know
one one of the uh when you were on the
podcast and I didn't read it today but
you're in that you're in that helicopter
and there's green Tracer fire cutting
through that thing and somehow you're
not getting shot like that's one that's
you know one minute of your time in
Vietnam that you shouldn't have survived
one
minute um so yeah some of the and I know
some of the missions in the follow on
book are going to be they're even
they're even more insane than the ones
in this
one
um when you would you uh sit down and
write for like an hour at a time two
hours at a time would you spend eight
hours writing how would you how what was
your
methodology it it would kind of depend
um and you know to be honest with you um
when I would go back to edit you know
the different missions and
things uh I would find myself there you
know reading it and realize holy cow my
heart you know is pounding and even
though I had read it 10 times you know
working on it reading it again and all
of a sudden I'm thinking about you know
what what was happening and you know
really get my attention so um take a
break wait a few days you know do it
again and uh so yeah I I remember those
things so
um but anyway
I I think it's you know if you look at
it as
if you want to
know get some taste of what war is like
and what happens on the special op
Battlefield I think anybody
from at least SOG
forward can read through here and relate
to well yeah you know these things
happen and that's what bullets sound
like and this all the stuff is going on
and the chaos of the the battlefield and
everything I think they can relate to it
I spent um some time just uh recently
with with the fifth group operators um I
went and spent some time with them and
uh you know they all had questions about
things and and they look at so guys as
this is kind of where our Legacy began
things we're doing now started back with
with the sog
guys and you know some of them with with
asked questions like so you didn't have
night vision you didn't have thermal
imaging and they' go through all this
list of stuff that they have now and
they would and they'd ask a question so
when you went to a building or to a camp
and you had to go in and and you know
accomplish a mission there how did you
do that if you didn't know where they
were if you couldn't see them and I said
well you
can you just don't do it with night
vision goggles there are other senses
that you have and you learn how to use
those because on today's Battlefield
when that EMP PSE goes out you're not
going to have night vision goggles
you're not going to have any of the
electronics that you have now all that
stuff is gone your headsets are coming
off because they're not going to work
and you got to be able to do it the way
we did it you know I can if you're in
the in the dark and I'm coming up
looking for
you I will smell you I will hear
you you will eventually move you'll get
scared your sweat smell changes your
heart rate's going to start to pound I
will hear it and you will move a little
bit I'll know where you are you won't
know where I am until you
feel that Kar go in and it's too late
then I'll find you I'll take you out
very quietly and then I'll move to your
buddy and you guys will be doing the
same thing without your
gear you're just not used to having to
do that
now and you know so we talked a lot
about different techniques of how to do
things there's a lot in here there's a
lot more in book two about being
invisible
ible how do you become invisible so that
the enemy can't see you and walking up
on him how do you walk up on that
joker and find him without him seeing
you so some of the techniques I put in
there things that that I thought
was should be classified I didn't put in
there things that i' rather not publish
and you know you give to the bad guys
and say Here's how you do some of this
stuff but when I meet with those guys
you know then we can talk about you know
some of the real techniques and how to
build the skill sets to do some of
that well I am definitely looking
forward to getting book too and uh
talking through that one when it comes
out yeah that that the what you guys the
Legacy that you guys left and the the
work that you guys did is just it's it's
it's hard to believe and if I wouldn't
have sat down and talk to so many of you
guys at this point and it it would be
I'm I'm glad I'm I'm honored to be able
to have had these conversations and
shake your guys' hands and and hear the
detailed stories you know this is this
is you know what I spent my adult life
trying to uh hold up the the reputation
that you guys set for Special
Operations and it's an honor to be able
to talk to you guys about it and and
share these stories and I'm I'm uh so
happy that you guys are putting this
stuff down and documenting with the
detail you know like hey part of me when
I started preparing for this podcast
I'll just read this whole damn book on
the you know just let's spend spend nine
hours doing it um but get the book if
you're out there it just phenomenal and
again it's really broken down the
lessons learned the experiences the
planning the training it's all in there
over and over again and you you hear it
for each different Mission so just
phenomenal stuff um and looking forward
to book to coming out and I certainly
always you know anybody from SOG has an
open invite to come on here and talk
about whatever you want to talk about I
I'm going to
listen um and and what else you got
going on you still got um the high
performing systems going on still got
high performing systems going on so
we're still doing a lot of work with
executive teams and you know uh
Consulting training we a lot of
leadership training we do uh decision
making under high stress we do a lot of
that we still have the um uh suicide PR
prevention going on using the Arsenal
assessment that we've created um the
Navy's picked that up now they're
starting to to use it um the Army's
still looking at it so there's a lot of
things like that going on um working
with vets working with veteran
organizations um to try to you know help
get these guys back I mean it's like I I
tell all of them when I work with them
the military spent a lot of time effort
and money to train you in the skill set
that we as as veterans once we leave the
active duty we think well that was all
good for the military but now I'm out
here in the civilian world and I have to
find my way around and what to do
and those skills still
work everything they taught you planning
organization all those things that they
taught you they still work out here in
in the civilian world in real life you
can apply them you just have to change
that mindset you know to but but they
still work and you can have a good life
you can manage the stress and you know
just like you know you'll hear it in
book two but like fear I mean we all
have things that we fear but if you if
you realize that one of the things that
fear does to you is it energizes you it
creates a big source of
energy it can cause you to freeze up not
do well not be able to think but if you
realize that's energy why don't I take
that energy and turn it toward being
positive and helping me accomplish what
I'm trying to do you know when I'm
riding in on the skill of the the
helicopter being on that insertion you
know on the the all adrenaline and
cortisol and everything's building up
rather than than being afraid and now
not being able to think about what I
have to do when I get on the
ground if I take that and turn it into
energy now I can focus better I can run
faster jump higher see better I can do
things much better or I can let the fear
let me be distracted so much by the
bullets and being afraid that I'm going
to be hit and focusing on that that
rather than what I need to do so I you
know turn it to positive using some of
the things that we talked about before
stress reduction techniques just on the
skid doing the breathing doing the Box
breathing going in you know and helps
calm you down help you focus help you
decide where you're going to go using
techniques like you know the headset wow
I mean that made such a difference all
of a sudden I could hear what was going
on and I didn't have to wait until I
stepped off the skid to start adapting
and trying to figure out what was
happening I I could get it on the way in
you can do that in your everyday life
you don't have to wait till the last
second to get information to find out
things you can do it and it works so
anyway we still do a lot of that so and
and uh does that get us up to speed for
right now where we're at I think we're a
little over four hours right now so I
don't know I'll stop talking so well no
I mean I'll listen I I listen to you
guys uh as long as I possibly can but
are we up to speed so you got you got uh
HPS
y.com is where your your high
performance systems is located you're
actually on on
Instagram um
HPS CEO right
you're also on Twitter do you ever go on
Twitter much uh I've started back
recently okay and it's the same thing at
HPS CEO you're on on Facebook dick
Thompson yeah um and I think that gets
us up to speed uh Echo Charles yes any
questions yes couple of questions here
I've been wondering this whole time so
RPD and RPG RPG rocket rocket propell
grenade RPD is what like a machine gun
of some sort a light machine gun okay
and and just RPG doesn't actually stand
for rocket propelled grenade it stands
for some Russian words that mean
something like that but it doesn't
actually stand for that oh for real but
it sounds good it does sound good yeah
right now I'm trying to wonder or
remember why I didn't think that then
someone told me that obvious it's it's
very common I'll say that you know I'll
say oh he got hit with a a rocket
propelled grenade but it's actually some
Russian words oh so so where did that
come from cuz it is a rocket propelled
grenade that's what it is but it
actually stands for this Russian words
that I don't know is that kind of like
um you know when you when they say uh
AR15 assault rifle 15 kind of like that
sounds but it doesn't really mean that
it doesn't really mean that okay all
right all right cool uh uh learn
something new every day what about a
Willie Pete grenade a white fucer okay
so so that's just a a slang name you
know because you you he it is you know
Willie Pete Wilson picket uh I mean
there must be about five different names
that that the G came up with to kind of
talk about it and it's stuck out there
but it's it's so it's a grenade and it
it's it's white phosphorus so it's like
a metal that burns at a really high
temperature what is it like shards of
metal or it's
liquid uh it's it's actually a white
phosphorus uh it's sealed up inside the
grenade container and when it's exposed
to air you know it starts to burn so
it's got a little detonating device in
it and it it explodes and it just throws
these little pieces of white phosphorus
out and all directions and kind of like
Napalm if it lands on your arm it it'll
burn all the way through or till it
burns itself out inside you so it's and
what's interesting is the blast radius
is Big yeah huge so like if you don't
throw it really
well you you could have a problem and
it's heavy it's a lot heavier than a
regular grenade and has a much larger
bursting radius so yeah if you don't get
it out there you'll you'll get hit with
it and then the um that dense white
smoke that's produced with it it really
meets the the specifications for a
chemical
agent if you inhale that stuff it'll
burn the inside of your lungs oh damn so
you know it's not something you want to
not cool be in that Willy PE grenade
okay so the white phosphorus versus
napom mhm napom is more of what like a
liquidy plasma type jelly
gasoline damn what's worse in your
opinion
well
I wouldn't want the Napal on me I mean
it'll just burn you all up the the white
flers is going to burn some holes in you
it may you know burn your arm off or
something but Napal can cook you fairly
quickly Raw Deal good to see you again
good to see you
again that it Echo Charles that's it
that's my deep you know all right sir
any final thoughts I appreciate the
opportunity to come back and um share
some of what's in there I think
um if if people want to like I said
before get a taste of of what the
special ops Battlefield is like I I
tried to do that with this there'll be
people and I say in front of it if you
don't want to know what happens out
there then stop reading don't read this
book or you're going to get upset this
is about war this about killing it's
about Special Operations and I tried
to make it
realistic to some degree I mean you've
been there you know what it's like it's
actually worse than what you see in here
um but it it will give you a taste of
what SOG people special operators
everywhere you know go through out there
so well uh sir thanks once again for
joining us uh like I said earlier it's
an honor to to talk to you it's an honor
to hear the stories share the stories uh
for from you and from the rest of the
sog
Warriors and you know like like I said
the the example that you all set you
guys you guys are my heroes you guys are
the the the people that um laid down the
path for all Special Operations and set
an example I don't think honestly anyone
will ever be able to to match what you
guys did um I just don't think it's I
just don't think it's possible I I just
really don't um you guys set a bar that
we can aspire to we will try and uphold
but we we won't ever be able to overcome
the the efforts and the sacrifices that
you guys made and so um the honor for me
to be here we'll never forget you guys
and um never forget the the men of SOG
and and especially the sog Warriors that
didn't come home thanks sir okay thank
you and with that uh dick dynamite
dynamite Thompson has left the
building I don't really I'm not I don't
have a big followup like you know what I
mean this just SOG
y um nothing else really comes close and
that's the way it
is agree I was going to ask about Rambo
cuz remember you told me recently that
Rambo's based on S or he's supposed to
be a saw guy yeah yeah I didn't even
catch that yeah but if you watch Rambo
again now you'll see that
there's I actually can we talk about
something else because I like literally
do not want to talk about Rambo right
now come on I was going to ask him about
Rambo if I'm glad you didn't was Rambo
representing that be right up there with
you asking adal MC if you have to be an
adal to be in the Navy it' be it
wouldn't be the same cuz that's let's
face it but it would be in the ballpark
well I mean that from your perspective I
understand how that could be for sure
nonetheless I didn't and you know I
thought ramble kind of represented but
it's I don't know how accurate my
thoughts would be because no Rambo's in
a movie yeah that's what I'm saying but
you know how like these guys are not in
a movie yes I know that but they didn't
even do
anything if you put what they did in the
movie it wouldn't seem unrealistic but
it's true yeah yeah so um um yeah and
you just it's good to remember and
understand how Brave and how tough and
how loyal and how smart and how capable
and how dedicated human beings can be
and maybe if we could try and be just
learn a little bit from that it'll help
us so um code name Dynamite get the book
stress effect I went and relistened to
the stress effect podcast that we did I
think it was
20 six maybe there was a few of them
right yeah well we did 204 205 206 so
206 we I listen to all of them again
they're epic but
um yeah check out get his books support
SOG SOG support it's what we're doing
over here also you probably got to
support yourself he talked about
physical fitness you want to be in good
physical fitness get
yourself some Jocko fuel Jo field.com
get yourself some of these energy drinks
some protein I just had a m Cookie by
the way do you know that I understand
well I I can sense it did you sense it
can you smell it no but you know how you
know like when someone just finishes
eating something and they sort of have
these little things going on CAU some of
that sens it in that way yeah uh Joo
fuel.com get what you need there from
the supplement perspective and it will
help you you can get those stuff either
at joof fuel.com you can go to Wawa you
can go to Vitamin Shop you can go to GNC
military commissaries AES Hanford Dash
stor wake Fern ShopRite HB down in TAS
Meyer out in the midwest Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields small gyms
everywhere if you got a small gym
Jiu-Jitsu gym CrossFit gym email JFS
sales joof field.com help your clients
be stronger faster and better Joo fuel
Doom check that out origin
usa.com we're making americanmade stuff
these guys were fighting the Chinese and
the Communists in the
jungles we're fighting them on the
economic Battlefield that's what we're
doing if you go to origin usa.com you
can invest in the National Security of
this country you can invest in Freedom
by buying a pair of jeans or a ghee or a
Rashard or a pair of
boots or a t-shirt or a
beanie at some point beanies became the
word like you know you stop calling it a
hat right I guess did you did you even
know what a beanie was when you lived in
Hawaii yeah how come it's just like
style it's not I yeah style you know and
I watch TV okay whatever it is it is
America still but yes no beanie is
widely unnecessary in Hawaii for the
most part but I understand where where
the question came from but if you were
to need one yeah you get one from origin
usa.com made in America right on best in
the world that's what we're doing sure
go to origin usa.com get yourself some
what else it's true also Joo store
called Joo store so Joo store this is
where you can get you discipline equals
Freedom whether it be a shirt a hat
hoodie beanies on there as well if you
want a discipline equals Freedom beanie
they're on there as well um Al so yeah a
lot of good stuff you like something get
something also on there is what we call
now the shirt Locker which is your
subscription shirt scenario different
design every month it's good people seem
to like that one but yeah check that one
out as well that that's where this
Stoner 63 made its appearance yep it's
true you got in some trouble over that
one yeah I did it's all good all good CH
store.com check that out also subscribe
to the podcast also check out Joo
underground jock underground.com we got
our own platform just in case let's say
the Communist take over here and we lose
control over the platform we'll still be
there on the Underground keeping it real
it real if you can't afford it cuz it
costs $8 $818 a month if that's a little
bit steep right now economy is rough
just email what is it assistant atjo
underground.com we'll get you taken care
of that way you can be in the game with
us also we got YouTube channels
subscribe to those Joo podcast origin
USA Joo fuel we all got our own little
YouTube channels we're putting out
different pieces of information there we
got psychological warfare we got flips
side canvas
we got a bunch of books look primarily
today SOG code name
Dynamite by Henry L dick Thompson he
also wrote the stress effect go and get
these books they're freaking epic also
I've written a bunch of books you know
what they are final spin leadership
strategy and tactics Field Manual the
code evaluation protocol all those
things dis freedom field manual the way
the warrior kid
books just get those books for the kids
you
know just go get them
let him have a better
life we have Mikey the dragons about
face extreme ownership dichotomy of
leadership just go just get those kids
books for the kids get the books for the
adults too but that's in your hands the
kid can't do this for himself possibly
he's seven years old he doesn't have a
freaking Amazon account like you do true
he doesn't know he's not listening to
this podcast right now this kid doesn't
know that his life can get better or her
life can get better they don't know that
you do
what are you waiting for like just be
generous also we have asalon
front it's leadership consultancy we
solve problems through leadership go to
Echelon front.com for
details we have live events that you can
go to we also
have a Consulting agency where you can
come into your company and help you
square away everything inside your
organization through leadership we also
have an online training platform at
extreme ownership. comom where you can
learn the skills of leadership for your
business and for your entire life on a
daily basis check that out extrem
ownership. comom also if you want to
help service members active in retired
you want to help their families Gold
Star Family check out markle's mom mama
Lee she's got a charity organization and
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America Mighty
warriors.org also don't forget about
Mike aink he's taken
veterans up into the Wilderness so they
can learn and reconnect with their
soul so check out Heroes and horses. org
and if you want to connect with us on
the interweb on Instagram and Twitter
dick Thompson he's on Instagram he's on
Twitter
HPS
CEO he's also got a Facebook he's at
dick Thompson and of course Ekko is on
social media he's at Echo Charles
I'm on social media I'm ad joa willink
listen just watch out because the the
damn algorithm will sneak up on you like
a freaking
tiger that SWAT your head
off so just be careful of that thanks
once again to Dick Thompson for coming
out here share his experiences share his
lessons learned more important thanks to
Dick
Thompson
for his incredible service to our great
nation and obviously uh salute to all
the sog
Warriors that fought a secret war and
sacrificed so much we'll never forget
what you did and the example that you
set for us and thanks to the military
people around the world that are
listening right now who are currently on
the front lines of Freedom we thank you
for what you do and to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thanks to all of you for the
sacrifices you make to keep us safe on
the home front and to everyone else out
there let's do a little
assessment do a little assessment of
ourselves I'm going to take a look in
the
mirror I will take a look in the mirror
I do take a look in the mirror I compare
myself to these men
the bravest the boldest the most
committed think of the
commitment these guys
had what am I
doing am I as committed as I should be
am I as focused as I should
be am I testing myself the way I should
be I don't
know but I'll tell you what I think
think about these men of SOG and I can
tell you this based on their levels of
drive and commitment and focus I know
factually that I can do
better I know I can do
better and I can do that every day by
going out there and getting after
it and until next time the Zeo and Joo
out